on va faire une interview première fois
tu es prêt
premier disque que tu as acheté au mieux
disque the piper at the gates of dawn
run away
et puis d'amis ainsi paraître non je
suis un fou j'aimais ses ambiances comme
ça très petit et c'est mon premier
disque premier film que tu as vu times
le premier film que j'ai vu c'est
blanche-neige marqué pour toujours
fanny films que j'ai vus ils ont blanche
neige blanche neige le premier fleurs
premiers flirts 12 ont réuni une vieille
de 16 ans or copine de wassen un masseur
en retard donc moi produite en situation
un passage notre caisse capelle paca
phase est celle dont je crois que c'est
un attrait à mulhouse mais c'est très
surprenant parce qu'on touche peut être
pas expliquer ça à mes copains de classe
qui veut s'acheter que de 40 bars au
supermarché c'était ses salles
électorale est maintenant finalisé au
look coup pour au moins trois ou quatre
premières idoles première idole viennent
avant de penser au derby
je crois que c'est françoise en fait
première idole c'est ça et les 10 de
près ce n'est que ma mère écoutait ouais
t'as méritait pas ça aide quand même
jamais son rêve ou première cuite
première cuite 15 en angleterre quand
j'allais travailler dans les hôtels est
vraiment la mort de très près la tête
dans la cuvette des chiottes toute la
nuit à la bière
je me suis dit que je n'aurais plus
jamais ça fait l'amour avec une fille 12
ans et demi atteints avec sa saison et
demie à c'était la totale
tout a commencé par toutefois oui bah
oui oui des garçons disons un garçon de
10 ans un copain de classe qui venaient
jouer à la maison
après les corps et c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé dans les têtes on s'est
déshabillé à y rester ans qui courait je
me suis mis sur lui on le truc
absolument désespérant rien ne se passe
donc on s'est rhabillé on a recours à
continuer à jouer en cernant a jamais
reparlé général
oui oui ça décolle de training la dent
c'est pas un mec quoi reconnait premier
se reconnaître
premier succès premier succès me disent
confiants à m louis ocana
oui dix corps maintenant premier succès
professionnel prenez succès
professionnel à mon premier disque quand
même sympa marche au niveau vente
c'était génial de pouvoir le voir en
vitrine à van noten n'a pas marché non
mille exemplaires signés par les arènes
et il va regarder toute la journée
c'était très déçu on fait un petit
centime ne met plus je pensais pas mais
millions premier million
un souvenir que j'affectionne
particulièrement c'était en 85 et avec
tombés pour la france la question qu il
en est tombé pour la france ça a changé
et carrément la vie y est à la fête j'ai
acheté une chaîne stéréo ce que j'avais
pick up encore c'est carrément les aides
pressante au niveau du matos il fige as
tu une chaîne
et ces sites et c'était extraordinaire
de pouvoir un peu d'argent devant soi
parce qu'on habitait dans un taudis en
neuvième
j'en avais vraiment va trouver la dalle
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas les deux
d'origine
c'est vrai c'est pas des souvenirs
malheureux des cancers premier concert
les transmusicales à rennes
20 minutes le hockey pendant 20 minutes
avec certains musiciens d'arc
des copains faire les choeurs c'était
bien c'est un bon souvenir ce premier
échec professionnel
je sais vernis j'ai pas de ce qu'on
pense pas vraiment d aide vraiment des
échecs je ne voterai sur le web non ça
va premièrement c'est plus des échecs le
personnel que chaque personnel personnel
22 ans
notre première
c'est ce qui m'a
le succès fut rien donc je fais des
chansons d'un premier million de
nouveaux francs
3 euros par jour là ça commence à venir
certes
ouais ça va au-delà j'ai pas tout
puisque je viens d'acheter un
appartement pour un maire donc il faut
je vendre quelques disques la première
télé et première télé fr3 rennes une
réalisation brillantissime maxi
l'utilisé parfois est un fou rire qu'a
durée auquel doit une tombe de la
chanson pacifiste et lundi pour rentrer
en ligne et la dernière volonté ça sera
quoi
ma dernière volonté d'être incinéré
dispersé
à la une façon fasse une grande fête
premier boulot j'ai dernier j'étais un
peu la boulangerie ouais j'ai d un feu
la boulangerie je livrais des trucs que
j'ai livré des pièces montées pour
pour les communions pour les mariages
tous à l'heure de donner une pièce
c'était avant la contre as well un
premier fleurs ah oui elle s'appelait
marie jeunes avant ouais mais j'habitais
dans une dans un petit village qui était
tendance catholique elle habitait dans
un autre village d'un kilomètre et
chainel c'était plus de protester et il
ya des problèmes dans l'alsace on se
rencontrait à mi-chemin dans l'alsace
ouais c'était l'enfer ce n'est pas le
droit de jouer avec les petits les
villes en face comme tu dis dans la
chanson
ba s'était coincée ou s y arriver les
juifs les protestants les cathos c'était
dur est vrai de vrai puis il y avait des
vieilles il y avait des idées des vieux
bouts de règlements de compte qui datait
de la guerre et intel qui avait dénoncé
l' intérêt et une telle qu'ils avaient
couché les rays qui portait la grêle la
transparence est la première fille mais
qui t'a fait l'amour souvient ouest une
brune ouais c'était pas terrible c'était
la sortie d'un cinéma on s'est retrouvé
dans dans un hangar entre entre une
moissonneuse batteuse et parce que tu es
dans un hangar
les machines agricoles tu vois et
j'étais très vite fait vers 17 c'était
déjà mieux premier gars ont commencé à
prendre les garçons avec qui les fait
l'amour
aubin je suis encore vierge de ce côté
là les oui oui je sais pas j'ai un jour
je me suis retrouvé dans un pieu avec un
mec comme ça il vendait comme un fouet
et même toucher à ben comme ça et moi je
voulais dormir d'entre eux j'étais
étonné par semaine parce que je le
faisais dont je trouvais ça fascinant et
a pas essayé
non maintenant fait car c'est dangereux
séraphin l'époque ça me paraissait
dangereux aussi
donc la tessera puis première [__]
ce sont 19 ans c'était pire charron
parce que je chantais dans un dvd put
rue pierre charron by eva un club qui
s'appelait le club pierre charon j'avais
été engagée je devais avoir 10 novembre
comme ça et je chantais cinq ou six
chansons tous les soirs avec une guitare
sèche
mon porte harmonica j'ai chanté des
chansons de dylan barry mcqueen
comme ça yves destruction de destruction
à grand moment parce que c'est très bien
j'aime beaucoup et il y avait des filles
barre et puis j'étais devenu copain avec
elle passait des nuits ensemble des fois
puis matin à me payer d'espagne c'était
super
le protéger car avant il aurait pu mal
tourner mais je ne voyais pas comment
des fins gg quand on parle de buts je
suis un peu choqué par le mou parce que
j'ai vu des filles super un premier
succès c'était beaucoup plus tard on
fait quoi
le premier suspect cabine jusqu'à dit
rien c'était carrément oui on peut pas
appeler ça
il y avait du bricolage partout entre le
moment où tu as décidé de devenir
artiste et le moment où tu es fait gaby
il s'est passé combien de temps dix ans
dix ou en disant tu y as cru a forcément
mais je rencontre toujours un conte qui
me disait écoute c'est bien ce que tu
fais
c'est bizarre expliqué genre de truc
pourquoi tu insistes ou
ces temps normal ce serait beau l'armée
ya peut-être certainement le fait que
j'ai essayé de bosser j'essayais de
faire détruire j'essayais de
mais je sentais tellement que il ya des
clips navy pouvait pas être vraiment 7
avec et
une envie de gagner de l'argent ennstal
je préférais mourir
ouais bah comme take devenue la compta
chez péchiney je te comprends besoin
j'ai vu tout de suite que traitement si
j'avais été comptable il ya un truc ça
marche pas c'est les musiques de films
tu as fais plein de 19,6 on le fait cinq
six mois et la convaincre sans sortie
pas pas une je sois ouais tu vas faire
assez d un jour avec les musiques de
films de passion des jeux mandatant
j'aimerais j'aimerais bien c'est sur un
quelque part je peux le remix et un jour
pouvoir collector's haythem un jour
premier million de nouveaux fronts oui
quand je devais avec bin ouais ouais
qu'est ce qu'on a fait je les ai pas vus
en fait les ai pas vus beaucoup il ya
tout de suite eu des impôts j'étais en
train de divorcer
ouais c'était un ramdam
incroyable c'est ça qui est fantastique
quand ça marche parce que tu vois très
grosse île et les choses fantastiques et
tu vois grossi aussi la connerie là et
la jalousie et tout ces trucs en plus
énormes aussi non premier procès
bondy bourse ouest peuvent laisser un
procès ça s'est arrangé allait demander
beaucoup elle a eu très peu ratée du
elle demandait trop ou alors elle fait
attention au nom de tous
c'est louche et à dernières volontés tu
devais mourir ça serait quoi
bon jeu prendra un bain
mon premier souvenir piquer des truffes
en chocolat dans un placard jouer du
piano dans un grand salon être enfermé
dans une cabane avec une grosse araignée
qui m'arrive de su monter à cheval sur
un canevas plastiques à la liste des
papables une fois tu arrives et le
problème que j'ai pas les odeurs être à
sinatra siècle est regardée dans
l'arrière de la cuisine non tu as dans
l'ain ton premier péché c'est sûrement
même temps mais ça pourrait être les
truies fort qu est il encore à
l'histoire de bonnes plutôt que ton père
était sous préfet non ouais c'est plein
de vannes chez vous faut ce n'était pas
vraiment pauvre pauvre pauvre comme ray
avait savez il y en a une qui maquille
mais qui s'appelait mignonne et qui
était assez charmante d'ailleurs et
allait m'emmener dans les bureaux elle
me montrer son derrière ça ne s'était
pas moi qui pêchaient était fort bien
ton premier fleurs
e
en provence en preuve assis sur des
troncs d'arbres puis la franche est
monté sur le trône d'un conte à une
après midi à s'embrasser c'est très très
difficile qui mettait la langue
je me suis renseigné auprès de mon
beau-frère pas le premier jour mais le
deuxième j'étais dire que j'avais appris
un nouveau truc sa première cuite
c'était sur le
c'est sur le bateau en angleterre le
malade à la bouteille de whisky de taxes
de brut
j'ai jamais été à mettre de l'argent
pourtant j'ai payé mes pas contact
pendant ce bref même quand tu avais 15
30 et j'ai eu l'idée
maintenant parce que je suis sûr que non
je réfléchissais maman a bien sûr que
non
première aventure chez lui avec un autre
garçon cette époque de la guerre des
boutons la guerre des boutons ça
m'excitait beaucoup quand ils attachent
le psychique je sais tout et ouais
j'avais un copain ça devait être en 8e
7e enfin en général presque tous mes
amis un stage là ça se finisse est
toujours dans des petits cagibi ou sous
la halle sous les tables les défenses
sent protégé par une table alors qu'ubs
est maintenant
maintenant ça réagit dans le guêpier
comptait pas [__] mais que mais bien
séduire les oslon ça reste platonique
resta ouais ça reste c
jamais pu monter à bord jamais
voilà où est fixée une acquisition de
deux éclairs voilà mais par contre ça
nous arrive d'y penser en tournée
particulièrement son premier voyage t'en
souviens à l'étranger c'est l'heure de
faire droit à l'angleterre
l'angleterre il ya eu plusieurs je me
souviens qu'avec lui on faisait la
manche dans le métro avant avec guitar
ou une guitare bhl on a toujours notre
jeu nous plaisir et je me suis un grand
voyage c'était avec olive on a traversé
les états unis en stop la surêté six
mois que j'avais dit à mes parents je
reviendrai en cadillac je serai riche
parce que ici la musique on n'y comprend
rien ça ne l'est pas là-bas la
californie là on est arrivé à new york
où il y avait louis à nouveau et singe
c'était très compliqué on a mis une
pancarte avec marc est ouest dessus
première banalisons paragon et un truc
qu'on est parti planeur et s'est arrêté
quatre mois comme ça puis après je
jouais dans un groupe à los angeles et
je suis revenu avec plus de ponts
partant de ces préfets moi je savais ce
que l'intérêt constant pas par un
militaire peu sous préfet mais mais bien
la poésie non j'aime bien toujours est
toujours très vigilant car dans ce que
je fais et il n'en voit aussi beaucoup
d'articles de journaux ont fait un peu
la collecte d'informations ce qu'ils
pensent qu'il pourrait me servir
quelquefois ça ne serve pas quelquefois
ça me sert c'est bon je pense que je
porte
faites un truc de génération en
génération pense que je porte des idées
qu'il a eue
c'est peut-être cela me sont couverture
de l'accusé
giguère d'applications sociales etc ton
premier pétard plus conciliant ouais
c'était quand
dans ma piaule de bonnes je vais réviser
le bac est un copain ou div
c'est le bon copain et voilà c'était de
duke a dû mazar i sharif au diamant
c'était complètement dingue et j'avais
un copain était le chanteur du groupe à
cette époque
on avait l'impression d'être dépuceler
d'une certaine manière en fait c'était
vraiment d'une certaine manière c'est
relatif dans le premier vote parce que
tes parents j'avais amené à la manif du
général de gaulle ray le 30 mai 68 nom
julien clerc aussi je lui aie a pas de
vente se sont dits oui je sais pas moi
je me souviens que je me souviens qu'il
ya un gars qui est passé avec les gens
un peu maigre et tout le monde est à la
fois l'ami moins une voix la bible ou ne
s'est pas réunie bible ni de gouges et
dany boon c'est un nom plus marrer je
n'ai pu voter alors non je n'ai jamais
voté
peut-être même même pour les écolos
d'une motte pha bon pour le chef de
classe avec audrey ann scott et les
échos notre vote pas pour eux non
l'histoire
je suis pas écolo moi j'aime bien la
terre j'aime la nature je réfléchi à
tout ça
cherchez pas faire c'est rigolo
mieux
mon premier souvenir c'était dans ma
chambre j'étais monté sur une petite
chaise que j'écoutais de la musique il
se faisait le break qu'il était chef
d'orchestre invasion et qui est mon
frère être secrètement stupides ne s'est
jamais l'environnement laporte amer et
et concertiste et et pianisme juillet à
quatre mains tous les deux non j'avais
un professeur adapté sur les allées
dwyane wade le pôle solfège
sinon c'était ma grand-mère marque piano
et puis la mer travail étudie tout le
monde croit que je sors du conservatoire
en fait c'est pas mal non pas
géotechnique du génial d'avoir produit
un bon pianiste qui est totalement seul
un bond très très mal et il a appris à
vivre avec ses défauts alors oui mais
aussi le premier disque que tu as acheté
ça c'est la charge
le premier visuel charte équipe j'ai une
pochette blanche avec un petit cube noir
ça lui fera à la maison quand même temps
c'est en tout cas à l'intérieur la
s'intéresse à faire dans quelque chose
la première fille avait quitté ses
labours bas était blond parce que moi je
suis très partisane de savoir pour qui
sur les longues années
c'était un match et c'est comme lire de
la musique sans connaître la partition
quoi première fois c'était au but
j'avais un petit studio c'est très très
vous perceviez à oui parce que je vais
moins 15 ans j'ai commencé à gagner ma
vie maintenant des chansons ce qui était
quand même très particulier et j'ai très
vite assez indépendant il ya le même
studio et voilà le premier garçon de
type push et l'amour et bien ça c'est
une expérience que j'ai pas eu en même
temps j'ai beaucoup de tendresse pour
pour les gens qui aiment les garçons ne
seraient pas contre un je serais pas
contre s'il ya bien un truc fils est
mort je suis incroyablement attirés par
les jeux ne doit pas avoir trouvé beau
un mec vraiment par exemple je te
trouvais pour aujourd'hui qu'est ce tu
ferais un jour aucun tabou moral par
rapport à cela la première chanson que
tu écris c'est vrai que c'est pour
bourvil et que c'était la girafe
ouais c'est ça n'at-il pas c'est un
sujet qu'il est vraiment aidé à voir ce
que pourront bien physiquement
maintenant mais c'est un type
extraordinaire moi j'étais je voulais
mourir acte avec bourvil c'était le
directeur artistique de cu des pâtes et
des petits s'occupait de la plaignante
me sens bien qu'ils étaient très c'était
une époque où c'était les jeunes qui la
loi il avait envie de vite de faire
travailler déjà le look a pourvu le web
et ont vu il était formidablement
hier trois tons floyd sur wii c'est la
vérité moi je n'ai pas écrit ensemble
pour vous parce que vous avez chanté moi
ce n'est pas du tout mon truc j'ai ce
qui m'intéresse c'est les beatles et et
mais moi écrivez moi ça au contraire
j'adore massa puis j'ai créé une chanson
pour lui il a absolument pas gentil
comme un truc c'est devenu ton semble
bon rythme mais ça m'a permis d'étudier
au parfum est ce que t'as pas vu un
complexe toi vis-à-vis du rock and roll
tu dis toujours je fais pas du rock and
roll fait la retenue nous y faire de 10
rebonds s'est pas complètement du
rock'n'roll est ce que t'as pas été est
ce que finalement tu es pas assez d un
côté bon élève et tu serais pas assez
dit ce treuil pour être vraiment
revenant à passer à l'intérieur ça se
passe et je pense peut-être ministre
aille à l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur un
handicap par rapport à sa part les
novices faire tout à l'heure ouais
sigler très très sage continuellement
ouest à leur bon gars ici bien habillé
en solo et je crois que c'est à
l'intérieur ça c'est ça c'est bien pire
première production c'est vrai que
c'était déjà limite fait jésus est un
allemand les règles en canulars ça m'a
permis d'aller l'explosion tendrait à
montrer un match et c'était un petit peu
seul idées de vos régions qui avait fait
ouais là toi nîmes et et nous on s'est
dit on n'arrête pas de nous dire oui
l'ami américain gil intéressant le rock
c'est fait pour les américains et on
s'est dit on va faire la liste
c'est comme chez lacan qu'elle chantait
ce peuple là personne ne savait que
j'étais nous comprend et donc les
programmateurs de radio ont dit voilà
c'est là c'est vraiment de la ligue
américaine et c'est maintenant c'est un
père malgré un break non c'est ça oui on
été pêché un petit pour chanter en
anglais est un type les temps a vendu à
nice et sarafina millions et après tu a
tout perdu en faisant un 33 tours
s'appelait puzzle voilà je ne sais quoi
ce polar j'avais gagné je vais me en
deux jours qu'un arc et symphonique
je voulais faire un concerto avec un
groupe avec une guitare électrique basse
et une batterie alors que ça et là j'en
ai vendu 310 des colonies plus celle que
je veux faire par la suite on était
dedans mais c'est un pied extraordinaire
je vais coûte de postes clés c'est
inaudible ton premier drame dans ta
ville cet écran le vrai drame 38 la
terre de mon frère était un frein très
proches y était
[Musique]
c'est lui qui m'a appris d'autres
beaucoup trop loin
la famille simple antoine s'est suicidé
aussi oui c'est vrai ça c'est le premier
drame
c'est un ami d'enfance avec lequel j'ai
passé toutes mes vacances qui s'est
suicidé 2 pourquoi je crois que son
histoire d'amour
justement y arrive ton premier amour
grand amour mais moi j'ai eu très peu
d'amour c'est véronique sanson
premièrement oui je crois que c'est à
peu près le premier important de héron
peu pourquoi tout ce que je sais c'est
qu'il faut demander qu'on lui a demandé
ses pour comparer c'est comme tournez
manège
l'émission qui veut épouser son deuxième
grand amour écoute je crois que c'est la
fille avec qui je suis maintenant
quand tu vois c'est pas franchement le
nancéien terme et de fidèles ouais assez
julien clerc nous a raconté que lui ont
quant à elles été avec lui il était un
peu dans l'ombre et que toi au contraire
il a mis dans la lumière crois que c'est
ça enfin dans de l'amour qui rentrent
vous parce que c'est ça qui vous a réuni
ailier pour longtemps je sais pas tu
sais je crois que c'est très difficile
de dire pourquoi ça ça va d'un couple
qui après ça va plus je crois que c'est
très très difficile est passé sa vie à
la même personne ça a l'air de
détournement dé loin ça va 100 ça
miraculeux légère quand c'est à dire
certaines années que ton premier succès
personnel
quant à chanter des chansons le premier
truc a vraiment marché de toit par toi
la vie du pianiste la coupe et du
pianiste
ouais ça a été tout d'un coup ça a été
incroyable parce que tout d'un coup deux
villages la tétée page et john john donc
non je sais c'est elle s'était déjà de
quatrième ou cinquième album enfin à
wimbledon gens qui commençaient à temps
ci comme chanteur s'était c'est à peu
comprendre ces capitaux et chansons pour
les autres
enfin d'autres grands exemple quand il
ya des moments où nous ayons j'arrête je
fais des chansons plus aux autres
mosaïques à bord n'ont à aucun moment
non classé c'est par un peu vrai ton pas
mes cheveux blancs s'en souvient et en
quelle année moi je sais avant dix mois
va voir tout ça t'a marqué c'est vrai tu
dois avoir des comme ça de textes pleins
de rêves 180 oui dans un article une
interview à georges marc benamou dans le
quotidien de paris tu veux avoir ton
premiers cheveux blancs et j'ai journée
tout un plat ouais je savais absolument
pas ce qui avait eu pour évoquer ton
adolescence et une enfance et j'ai de
faire une petite interview première fois
des prêts oui première bo première boum
un message me rappelle de tout les
boomers toujours pareil m'inviter pour
faire rire
la première partie de la soirée puis dit
que l'esl war iv ont demandé de rester
près du buffet j'ai des années en moi
c'est une fille première idole premier
rideau hall of commence à se savoir
jeudi que j'aime vraiment beaucoup
claude françois
tu connais toutes ses chansons par coeur
a pas mal pas mal mais je suis pas
fétichiste pour moi je dis ça j'ai
acheté un costume du bio aux enchères
est ce que tu sais qui a écrit les
lundis au soleil
ouais c'est qu'il y ait un copain
s'appelle patrick g bravo on n'a pas
dire
en même temps
premier fleurs premiers flirts c'est
dans un autocar dans le fond avec la
plus belle en direction de l'italie
j'étais j'ai dit le dernier dans ma
classe de beach soccer il est à l'avant
les années de mac à sortir avec une
fille oui je suis bien passé quand même
bien ou bien j'ai pensé qu'on peut pas
si pire est finement ci fut première
cuite
la dernière salle entière alors là pour
éviter aux jeunes en sus votre en boutre
au lycée ouais ils sont soit pas
particulièrement
non non non non je te bourrer du premier
vrai amour premier vrai amour ce doit
être un muret drogba je vous que je suis
là m'entendais bien amoureux d'elle
première expérience sexuelle
ah bah oui on m'a dit moi il fallait
absolument je vais merde j'avais 19 ans
enfin absolument que je passe à l'acte à
l'acte et je me suis renseigné sur la
fille la plus facile du lycée qui est
tout est accepté
c'est passé comme une lettre à la poste
1er juin 1er juin c'était ça longtemps à
la police et au volant il ya pas
longtemps au nom collège au collège le
collège font soutenu à j'étais vraiment
on était fous comme ceux de n'importe
quoi en fumée du café du thé premier
procès dans l'est pas encore oh non il
ya non non j'ai voulu en faire un point
sur un cône ap le wermus la wallonie ça
qu'est ce qui t'a dit grand reporter du
salon de thé qu'est-ce qui m'a dit mais
qu'il avait dit je vous le rappelle
rappelons le cap allemagne n'était autre
qu'un pâle imitateur de sylvie joly donc
ça m'avait énervé quoi qu'ils le disent
qu'ils ne dévoilent premier vide premier
bid se soit 10 mois alors je vois tout
ça c'était pour t'amener pour remuer des
souvenirs d'enfance et d'adolescence je
suis très heureux
bah oui est ce que tu as fait longtemps
pipi au lit
non pas plus que je m'en souvienne ta
mère tu en parles pas là tu sers à
quelque chose qui a marqué dans la
famille non on va faire une interview
première fois ah ouais
préfère-t-on premier souvenir par
exemple c'était comment je me suis
retrouvé à avoir un caniche au lieu d'un
mouton
comment ma vie comme ça et j'avais dit
au marché qu'elle était dans mon village
à maywand et j'étais tombé mais
complètement amoureuse d'un petit mouton
tout blanc mignon au jeu devait avoir
quoi quatre ans et je dis je veux le
mouton je veux le mouton et jetez la
même époque mais mignon et ma mère me
dit écoute on va rentrer à la maison et
on reviendra tout à l'heure le chercher
parce que tu vois je suis chargé tout ça
et je fais bon ben d'accord
sachant très bien elle que le marché
sont allés à 1h
elle me ramène le mouton tu vois il est
parti membre
là je n'ai pas bougé je me suis jetée
par terre ça a été terrible il a fallu
aller chercher mes grands parents et mon
grand père a dit attends bien la maison
je te promets que je vais tram n'est
peut-être pas un montant mais quelque
chose qui ressemble il est allé le
chercher un caniche nain très belle
histoire
ton premier baiser dans la cage
d'ascenseur
parce que tu dis pas tu as dit que en
fait le coup de la langue que j'ai vu
dans union parce que chez toi quand tu
étais petit y avait des revues comme ça
qu'ils qui traînait avec union et puis
avait déjà vu qui venait dessus elle
aussi tu es vraiment gentil couple à
l'enjeu l'évident union si tu savais ce
que je vis dans l'union et dans d autres
domaines qui avez chez vous
les coûts de la langue choisie par tous
c'est ça car il y avait de tout
absolument être vidéo c'était assez joli
il s'agit des compositions absolument
c'était des pages pleines tombe au père
à l'époque tu as vu en train de lire en
cachette ces revues qui l'a remarqué je
les lisais pas si je l'avais parmi tout
à fait à la bonne place c'est à dire en
fait tu n'as pas besoin de te cacher
pour lewis à nous emmerder
il m'en parle mais moi je faisais oui je
sais je sais y'a pas de problème est en
fait lui avait pas trop mais c'est
beaucoup moins drôle si c'était permis
non non c'était passé as été absolument
pas ça toute façon je le faisais dans
dans l'idée que c'était permis moi j'ai
jamais eu le sentiment que c'était
interdit
non c'était pas ça c'était que c'était
comme une intrusion dans mon intimité
oui érotique il est affectueux même nom
ne peut pas dire on t'a dit ouh c'était
tout à fait qu'ils se balader à poil à
la maison mais tout le monde se balader
à poil
et même la neige même le tennis la
première expérience sexuelle
c'est à dire la chose c'est qu'a dit la
chose sexuelle
ça veut dire quoi tu veux savoir quoi
exact la première fois tu t'es fait
sauter du principe non mais si tu n'as
absolument pas précis parce que dans la
première fois que tu te fais sauter je
peux te dire mardi matin 11 heures
la première fois dans ta vie ni ben
hardy matin au genre ça répond à ta
question n'est pas fait six tapis à
présent et demi en fait non je vais te
dire ma question je veux savoir si
c'était ton ton parolier duval ou ton
compositeur allen ski parce que je ne
sais pas très bien mais coutu leur
demandera sa première télé c'était en
belgique c'était une émission de ça
plaise quoi génération 80 nouvelle
traque ans vous avez vous mis un certain
temps maintenant ça va tu as pu le trac
si j'avais encore le trac en fait ce
soir j'ai pas le traite donc au but vide
le premier bide finalement je sais pas
c'est peut-être quand j'ai signé mon
premier contrat de disque j'aurais
peut-être dû réfléchir à deux fois j'en
sais rien mais en tout cas je sais que
mon premier beau bid c'était quand
j'étais en simple dont premier noël
je m'en souviens pas un particulier mais
je me souviens bien de la préparation
autour de noël
un an gwan au portugal parce que on
aller avec mon grand père coupait un
sapin à la tombée de la nuit
il disait qu ibra connaît enfin je suis
même pas sûr ça fait peut-être dans un
terrain derrière chez lui mais c'est
participer complètement à l'aventuré
c'était bien et puis on est allé
cueillir la mousse au pied des arbres
pour en tapisser la crèche
dis moi tu veux faire une interview
première fois justement sans rapport
avec les marouani et tout ça une vraie
interview première fois ci c'est aux
caisses ou d'alcool dans les bars où ils
sont très bien du tout en arrière dis
moi ton premier souvenir cinq ans ouais
quel anniversaire
un anniversaire dans une dans mon petit
village à juillac avec des éléphants
dessinée sur le mur tout ce que je me
souviens quand mes souvenirs je crois
que c'est ça c'est assez nette
d'ailleurs cinq ans ma grand-mère réputé
dans un petit truc avec la radio sur la
table
tiens tu avais pas ton père tu es né de
père inconnu
tu peux les coeurs comme tu veux mais
j'ai aussi né de père inconnu et tu dis
finalement c'est très bien comme ça
ouais ouais ouais c'est très bien comme
ça on va dire que c'est très bien comme
ça ouais ouais ça parce que ça m'a
motivé sama a revanche enfin connue non
je le connais tu connais maintenant je
le connais j'ai fréquenté en fait de
croiser pendant des années il ya
quelques temps j'ai parlé et puis les
reste inconnu tu habites ont lu ta
première baffe sur d'autres les copains
à l'école parce que justement c'était de
faire un coup et c'est pas ta mère non
sur mon toit surmonte ta mère elle
s'appelait d'aidé s'appelle toujours des
vrais et elle avait un côté un peu non
comme la merde depardieu un peu je ne
sais pas parce que des parties d'une
mère comme si c'est ça un peu là venez
on va mère ma mère c'est plus que la
moitié de moi siècle aux jouets 109 me
ramasser à la petite cuillère
et puis c'est un c'est un rocher c'est
plus qu'un rocher temps premier flirt ou
t'en souviens c'est laurette s'appelait
c'est une rousse
j'ai embrassé sur la joue je suis parti
en courant ouais c'est content j'avais
10 ans 10 ans en cède bien ta première
sans gêne gennetines mémoire fait j
j'adore cette époque première cuite
la première voiture je me rappelle bien
chaque des potes avant de avant la
veille de la rentrée des classes on l'a
fait quelque chose quand même ce que
c'est beau à la gueule à l'isara à ses
ordres et sucre et non à boire c'est dur
à vomir c'est sucré oh la la c'est
l'horreur mais tu sais ce qu'on avait
fait tellement était bourré on a voulu
se faire du café gala je ne conseille à
personne faut vraiment être tordu pour
le faire on a pris la machine à laver
on a mis le café moulu dans le truck
coutumes et la poudre à l'époque il y
avait un tuyau qui sortaient les
saloperies mais on attendait que la q1
c'étaient des mesures contre 1406
s'emballent c'est ça non non tu fous
travail 30 francs ces 30 bal à l'époque
l'avait au panier c'est 30 francs le
pénitencier c'était 30 francs pour du ca
lui c'était 40 francs c'était en 74
c'est pas si vieux que ça c'est un peu
dur pour bouffer quand même un ton
premier bid trop plein avec les
gonzesses
qu'est-ce que j'ai pris on va voir on
remarque que maintenant j'ai appris un
ouais j'ai imprimé
non non tu sais les nanas moi j'ai plus
j'étais vachement complexes et un grand
nez oreilles tout était trop vent comme
les éléphants
ouais pareil j'ai deux choses de
l'éléphant j'ai la mémoire aussi et puis
en plus pendant des années je jouais si
je me faisais des moches pas et un jour
enfin on va aller jouer autant je me
faisais des films et puis un jour je me
suis dit pourquoi tu essaies rep ah les
belles mais elle est très belle et
celles qui sont sur la couverture des
magazines étouffé aussi à chaque fois
j'en croise il non non c'est pas pour
moi avez-vous est en fait faut oser
est-ce que c'est pas plus dur mais pas
avant ils ont tendance à vue et même des
fois tu te demandes si les belles sont
pas plus faciles que moi peuvent être en
plus l'habitude c'est sûr eu 400 balles
ben ouais mon premier mariage a c'est
très bien c'est génial à 7 15 ans et
demi non non non saison nba 16 ans et
demi saison n est qu une dispense du
président de la république vous avez
tiré ensemble vont être fous puis j'ai
assumé tout de suite ça j'ai assumé tout
de suite j'ai voulu j'ai voulu faire
bouffer ma femme que c'est tout donc je
me suis mis à bosser
j'ai même passé un concours de flics que
j'ai pas eu heureusement [__] tu
imagines juste ranger ma forme d'un joli
raté d'un point tu te rends compte
deuxième mariage on oublie tu puis on
parlait de sa poche
troisième mariage les trucs qui toi du
quatrième cas connus ou méconnus à c'est
un copain qui m'a présenté sur un
plateau et puis après on s'est connu à
val d'isère dans un gala j'étais parti
que les cocos coeur et je me disais dans
la catégorie coco girl il manque un truc
à ma collection
ouais ça j'avais un moment je c'est vrai
que je reconnais que j'ai fait je me
suis fait un challenge à savoir je vais
taper speakerine machin je vais essayer
coco girl mais en fait c'est parti comme
ça et je ne suis pas du tout partie avec
mais j'ai vu que cette fille là si elle
mettait la main dessus
c'était cuit et on en fait on sait le
hasard c'est une chose bête on sait on
s'est vraiment connu le soir où connu
chez mort parce qu'elles habitaient chez
coluche c'était une amie de coluche
nami tout bien toute amitié habiter chez
coluche
et puis on sait
on s'est téléphoné soir coluche est mort
le 19 juin 86 on s'est revus on s'est
mariés on a fait un petit lait né le 19
juin
91 c'est bizarre ça va et entre-temps
coluche s'est tué en moto et mon fils
c'était aussi un hasard à savoir c'est
vrai que le petit benjamin
quel âge il a aidé à six mois ouais
c'est vrai qu'il ya déjà coupé quatre
fois les cheveux défi c'est comme si ces
monstres mais moi je les peurs ouais
t'es sur lui mais lui il a des cheveux
ses monstrueuses jamais vu ce dont il
est sûr qu'il a toi un vrai ouais il
présente même s'il était noir il sera
bon ouais c'est vrai pour une interview
première fois oui c'est la première fois
que l'on fait sécher par agent ne serait
jamais prêt premiers souvenirs remontent
en cinq ans je suis né j'ai sorti du
ventre de maman et il y avait plein de
gens blancs qui me regardait opinion ma
maman elle freine ses frères au premier
péché le premier fait ce n'est pas ma
maman elle était abonnée au quintal
thermolactyl de damart et un jour je les
feuilleter en cachette comme ça jeudi
l'onu j'ai des pensées impures première
boum c'est pas méchant
la première boucle j'ai vomi pourquoi
parce que mes qu'un parent aimant les
waf du whisky coca
sauf qu'ils avaient oublié de main du
clan 15
le premier iron maiden point les pommes
oui premier fleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors channel il avait été l'oeuvre
mme elizabeth taylor d'aujourd'hui
estime m
première cuite tamanrasset cessé à
droite ou à gauche là
expériences sexuelles
c'était avec une boîte de cirage ton
raisons qui m'avaient attachée à un
arbre et après ils font les entoure et
chante un pin du tribun organes
mon premier voyage d'un premier voyage
je m'en souviens pas c'était un système
pas un fenêtre
c'est le tout premier choix et on 1er
juin bon alors ça c'est un jour où je
mes parents ils vont regarder là je
pense que oui c'est un genre j'ai une
randonnée avec mes camarades dans la
forêt et on avait décidé d'attraper des
crapauds pour les faire fumer
steven problème c'est qu'on n'a pas
attrapé le crapaud quoi oui c'est moi et
il en fait fini
je fais mon premier succès c'est un jour
j'ai réussi un personnel marchand de
journaux de novembre quant aux quelques
années quand on sait le journal où tu
vois tout ce qu'il ya dedans les dames
et des gones à sa première interview la
tv
l'interview la télé instance était dans
une par ailleurs avec monsieur philippe
gildas et je tiens à lui rendre hommage
parce que c'est un grand monsieur
enfin non
et ta dernière volonté ça serait quoi
bon du moins je peux venir
bah si tu veux oui alors un temps de la
monarchie comme ça c'est moi qui
prendrai est ce que tu es prête pour
faire une interview première fois
première baffe
je n'ai jamais été giflée enfin pas mes
parents s'entend par les copines sa
charpente mais par les hommes
sympa non un bon jamais à le premier qui
essaye on a fait le premier noël premier
noël oui j'avais une jaunisse je me
souviens j'avais une très belle robe de
chambre jaune assorties justement
hommage à nice premier objet fétiche à
l'ours dont j'avais arracher les
oreilles et les yeux tu la gardes et
j'ai toujours eu peur avec non c'est pas
avec lui tu dois premier péché premier
péché qu'est ce que j'ai pu faire une
bêtise en effet hall à l'ag de trop
d'enfants tu sais tiens moi mon premier
péché si je peux pas le raconter à la tv
on va visionner entre nous dans l'été
deux petits copains comme ça on était
jeunes qu avec l âge cet ange a déjà
annoncé passage
tu jouais à quoi qu'en tout petit
j'étais chef de bande
tu joues et tu préférais jouer quand tu
étais petit à cache-cache au docteur à
cache-cache jeu mais jouer tellement
docteur même si j'ai chanté docteur
jettent ensuite vient la première boum
j'avais 19 ans et demi je suis resté dix
minutes pas plus couper les ponts c'est
quoi qui ne plaisait pas
les filles et les garçons soient serrés
les uns contre les autres les retraites
ah ouais j'ai fait le service militaire
dans sa vie savoir de façon première
idole c'était kit dorothée à toi c'était
fred astaire ginger rogers et surtout
aux drivers premier flirt ou t'en
souviens c'était qui en angleterre on
est des plus grands très grands très
très grand qu'est ce qui s'était passé
exactement
ils sont juifs c'était gentil tout ça
continue d'être un petit mot sur la
première cuite
certainement après un spectacle quelques
jours après le jeu de la vérité de
chantal goya
sympathie premier amour je ne fais pas
plus cher que je te parle d'amour quand
même des muscles et quelque part on va
se passer je crois qu'il ya un bon
contact avec la dame claire manavit sont
musclés fais gaffe et sur cinq sont
grands mais aussi il y en a cinq faits
mais sa grâce à un bon premier amour
alors hausse était très gentil très très
très romantique et romantique bon
première expérience sexuelle
ça s'est très bien passé merci c'est
vers quel âge à cet art là aussi
d'avant-hier veut battre
je comptabilise plus fait gaffe c'était
vers quel âge où j'avais 18 ans quand
même
ouais et alors c'est très beau à
regarder un bon souvenir
tu la revue à ces cas c'est le mutisme
arrivé 1er juin tu as fumé
j'avais jamais fumé de dollars je crois
pas écoute si elle te dit qu'on allait
être sincère mais les df bon d'accord
premier succès
côté télé côté 10 côté premier succès de
ta vie la première fois où tu t'es dit
tiens ça y est ça marche
y'a pas d'hier non il n'a pas d'hier
n'avait rien ne prendre que deux claques
dans la gueule
je vais arrêter là premier succès je
crois que c'est où la menteuse je crois
ou la vraie manger pendant là dans la
rue les gens m'ont dit à la menteuse et
amoureuse c'est quand les gens dans la
rue te parler tu m'écoutes fabien marché
à new york 1er millions d'anciens francs
mais pas trop longtemps n'y a pas très
longtemps
il est dit que rien j'ai pas tué mais il
a peur du tout aussi fournie à tomates
hachées
c'est la première fois que je vois
quelqu'un me torcher le film s'est vite
un bravo premier million de nouveaux
faut juste pas être honnêtement j'en
sais rien c'est justement contre je sais
pas ce qu'on me dit attention des thons
rouges bomba d'accord
attention tout passe dans la drogue le
premier geste que tu fais le matin je
râle je croyais tiens c'est une question
piège la caisse doit se découvrir
qu'est ce que tu fais le matin
c'est pas allumer la tv non cette
deuxième c'est comme mtv chez toi une
dans chaque pièce
ça fait combien tu sais qu'on est le 21
mars et le 1er quoi c'est le 21 mars
dans les 30 premiers jours du printemps
eh oui dis moi toi tu es prêt toi aussi
envie de qui est un battant c'est à
l'oreille après le home energy me casse
mon pour le lot à chaque après coup
d'avoir j'espère une interview première
fois des prêtres ou 1 on est dans
l'enfance dans les enfants dans les
mamans les papas ton répéter j'en ai
tellement le premier que tu as fait
avec une petite caméra lui envieraient
tiens
énormément jouer à touche pipi cousin
est aussi très marrant je sais que
c'était à moi et mes potes avec l'épousé
wade mais c'était vachement décousu mes
copains d'épouser un goût parce que moi
c'est que je vais revoir maintenant et
que je doive céder messieurs ah je
pensais arriver peut-être coupe je m'en
souviens vous tu vois je me dis ce gros
becs barbu tout je veux publier avec lui
et évidemment banon il s'en souvient
peas qui me fait rire c'est qu'ils s'en
souvient absolument pas les gens
résistent à leur mémoire mais je crois
que les enfants jouent moins touche pipi
non on jouait beaucoup tu veux pas
touche pipi moi j'ai eu tout le temps
quand j'étais petit je veux aussi bien
ses missions pas qu'ils en font de
maintenant moi je sais pas moi j'ai deux
filles pour le moelleux son petit je
sais pas encore je te dirai ça dans
quelques temps des synergies je vous ai
dit je sais pas
je suis sûrement pas un péché
l'embrasement repêché pas mettre à la
tête des gens surtout des premières
boums première boum
première boum de 12 13 ans que ça fait
boum rouler des pelles
c'est ça se serait arrêtée là on avait
très hâte et torch est un peu non est ce
qu'on disait à l'époque n'ont prononcé
mais non c'était des pétards des pétards
des jeunes pendant 30 ans peu plus vieux
quand même moins 16 ans chez sa mère
d'une copine entre les deux premiers
flirts c'était la première fleur c'était
dans une boum
il ya eu baisers profonds ou sans
papiers oui mais le vrai le vrai des
épreuves orales anglais tout la première
fois que tu t'es retrouvé toute nue avec
un garçon a jeté h quoi étonner et lui
donc
j'ai surpris que ça sonnait tout droit
sur tout ouais sous une douche à lui
l'arrivée sous la douche
non c'était ça a commencé en bas comme
tous les garçons puis un moment ça s'est
mis en route et ça m'a tellement étonné
et que du coup c'est la déconcentrer et
après je suis plus donc on coucher pas
si facilement quand même à l'époque
ouais bah justement on y arrive première
expérience sexuelle mais avec
pénétration c'est toi qui explique
clairement de façon à ce qu'ils aient
pas d'ambiguïté je sais pas si j'ai une
vie de famille j'ai trois enfants
c'est vrai c'est ouais
battre est de très mignon fait j'étais
très amoureuse d'un garçon qui était
très amoureux de moi et on est restés
ensemble pendant cinq ans a bâti des
empires et il garde un bon souvenir de
cette première phase annonce était
vraiment un père d un choix comme vous
pour plein de gens plein d'anadys la
première fois tu dis quoi c'est ça c'est
un peu déçu et un peu d'issues première
expérience homosexuelle
l'expérience nous c'était une époque je
suis de la génération il faut lier tous
ici c'était est tout aussi alors on a
tout ici et même la télé mais et alors
je m'étais dit et puis tu étais vraiment
ringard c'est avait pas une expérience
homosexuelle
moi ça me disait rien du tout mais je
lui disais que mourir que d'être
ringarde
donc j'avais repéré une nana qui était
plus plus du gazon maudit tu pouvais pas
et je m'étais dit bon va falloir que je
mal face à va pas ça ne payait rien du
tout il faut que j'y aille quand même tu
vois et puis j'y suis allé mais alors
bourg et comin quoi et puis je ne sais
pas ce qui s'est passé
le seul truc les méandres matin elle m'a
dit allez donc t'es pas une affaire ah
ouais t'as pu recommencer parce que si
tu fais ça me fait ça vaille pas
beaucoup de plus puis surtout c'était
pour l'avoir fait toi moi je les fais je
suis tu l'as fait d'être ok je suis
tranquille première par tous ça c'était
ah ça c'est m
et ça c'est les jeunes qui voient pas
maintenant ils sont comme ça éviterait
point ces maillots
c'était dans le segment par an tu crois
si bien dire j'étais chez un camarade je
suis un camarade qui me dit viens on va
chez des amis boire un verre lave toi on
s'échange des culottes ans et j'aime
non non pas du tout je ressentais un
petit ami d'époque et tout puis on
arrive dans cette boue mais on était
jeunes on avait 15 16 ans tu vois qu'ils
avaient des matelas partout on était les
premiers mois j'ai pas vu le truc venir
toi et puis au bout d'un moment vont les
gens comme un simple toit a flirté tout
ça mais bon c'est dit je me suis dit bon
toi il y voit un peu fort mais après
tout la fois il a commenté y ont
commencé à ceux dé saper et au bout de
deux heures tout le monde était
franchement a poli avec moi qui va
crochète papier tout et puis là il m'a
dit quand même attachement coincé comme
dana et tout est là j'ai dit ouais je
cherche ma pensée comme nana détail un
fait nous a regardés comme non non non
je suis parti j'étais assez moment je te
promets non mais pourquoi aujourd'hui
roland ok on continue deuxième temps fut
en son temps complet
alors la première cuite
voilà je suis souvent bourrés parce que
je vois pas beaucoup donc je suis très
vite bourré et comme les gens qui
boivent pas beaucoup je suis vite vos
années tester jeunes un programme très
humble ces jeunes auront hui ont
sûrement ouais mais j'ai senti bien
premier pétard alors ben une une la mère
d'une copine de classe 10 11 12 ans
voilà un petit peu tôt mais c'était
avant le pétain toute façon expérience
12 ans tu tapes et avec le recul de ses
parts à peu se dégonfler ouais premiers
acides jamais g120 ils n'ont jamais
d'asile parce que j'ai vraiment là je
trouve que les mecs elle était tellement
collé au bol des plaies un wagon quand
même mon coin ils réagiront les connais
bien maintenant c'est une espèce de
regard content que ça vous oubliez se
couper les cheveux à will you be tu as
well as you can't interview ce we are
used to practice et mme fichaux de first
one de faire sauter un avion
le festival
sofia face jobs fast milliards $ in the
way to die know what will be you lie to
me faire une petite interview première
fois ses premières fois c'est quoi
première fois par exemple venir ton
premier souvenir pourquoi les souvenirs
c'est un rêve
ouais c'était quoi c'est un loup est un
renard qui ne parlent dans un jardin et
qui viennent me dire que l'ère de pouce
seront là je regarde
non c'est sérieux c'est vrai encore le
vexer et je regarde vers le ciel et je
vois une fenêtre qui s'ouvre
j'essaye de parler à cette fenêtre cette
fenêtre ne répond pas j'étais pas lu ton
premier pétard c'était mon premier
souvenir c'est la première baffe la
première baffe en fait la première dont
je me souvienne c'était dans une île il
ya un mec qui m'a chopé parce que je
parlais à sa copine enfin tout à fait
banale et il m'a chopé je me sente en
défense je me souviens négocié un négoce
c'est pas beau ton premier objet fétiche
tu t'en souviens on est en effet direct
et tout au fond la colle et le mec dans
son coin comme ça vous arrive et j'ai
maintenant je peux aller danser ça
c'était la première boum ray simple
amélie ta première idole
apprenez redone j'ai pas eu d'idole est
pas une idéale si peut-être un peintre
que j'aimais beaucoup qui s'appelle paul
klee mais c'est vrai c'était pas mike
brant où il a dit un peintre il n'a pas
d'une tâche
ton premier amour vrai amour mon premier
vrai amour sénat m'a tuer la tête et
j'ai ramé comme un dingue pour la voir
j'ai vraiment ramé ramé le jour j si
c'était bon coin jarry a pas une combine
avec sa soeur un copain à moi un truc
incroyable juste pour la voir elle et
j'ai pu en mobylette j'étais super
russie avant tout à fait génial ça
marche on a eu un accident tous les
trophées vision de la gueule
son orgueil arracher un jeu populaire la
triste ça c'est mon premier amour est
maintenant mêlée mais vachement première
expérience sexuelle ça s'est passé plus
calmement
non ces gens pareils ces genres gens
incroyables tout l'été jean dernier
moment c'était genre
la porte qui s'ouvre dans le couloir
voisin dans la chambre la porte sous
dans le couloir un bruit gens tu chéris
et à part moi qui s'oublie de partir par
la fenêtre on aperçoit même vient
d'annoncer que sa première cuite à
première cuite m'a satisfait parce que
j'étais bourré que t'es bourré tape
accueillir le premier président richard
premier pétard le premier pétard
je me souviens d'une grande paranoïa
première vraie grande part à nous amuser
avec le premier pétard ça c'est clair
premiers acides première a cité seul
s'est jetée jamais redescendu samarie
c'était à la campagne oui mais qu'est ce
que tu as vu parce que non j'ai rien vu
j'ai pu je fais ça parce que c'est vrai
j'avais mes doigts comme ça ce coup j'ai
vu mes doigts qui fit sa série de
l'arrêter avant mais j'ai arrêté c'est
vraiment spécial
ton premier succès ses premiers succès
ouais c'est quoi un succès j'ai passé
mon amitié succès letton pythie ouais
c'est un succès que j'ai vachement plus
tard ouais mais avant je n'avais vu des
petits quoi genre ferait du bien
ouais jean le bon plaisir ça m'a
vachement du bien fort saganne aussi ses
dauphins manon et puis là mon magnifique
piscine à la première télé du temps
souvient en tournage je te dis où on
notait un comme ça en invités on éviter
cette carte charnière qui m'invite pour
claire gens sont des missions qu'ils
allaient et mardi cinéma
ouais mardi cinéma c'était au moment où
il y avait des manifs dans la rue
peut-être 86 d'étudiants et d'étudiantes
et je sais pas j'ai commencé à me
prendre la tête avec un truc sur astérix
un film qui étaient faits en face
terrain je me suis échauffé tout seul
moi j'ai gueulé quoi je me souviens très
bien que la dernière m'a dit mais vous
savez parler aussi c'est simple je suis
moins bien ça pourquoi tu veux pas aller
à secret soirée c'est quoi ces
accessoires
tu travailles comme ça et tu fais des
exercices pour améliorer ton nom
mêlerons pas un acteur qui a beaucoup
travaillé avant justement dont tu
travailles way et je suis obligée de
travailler avant de caler film sur
déroule parce que je suis pas bon et
c'est vrai que tu fais des exercices
pour apprendre à rire je fais des
indices pour essayer de pouvoir
peut-être un tout petit peu donné l'idée
que ça pourrait être un bon soir thierry
alors on va prendre les choses par le
commencement
on va te faire une interview première
fois est ce que tu es prêt je suis tout
à fait prêt bon alors ton premier non
c'est pas du tout enrico macias dans ce
gaston ghrenassia alors national rin
assia exactement parce que ma première
pochette cité gaston ghrenassia et le
directeur de commercial de ma maison de
première maison de disque et il
n'arrivait jamais à se rappeler de mon
nom est alors il a demandé à ce que je
le change moi ça ne me plaisait pas
tellement mais enfin bref j'ai dit bon
je vais le coupé comme j'étais déjà
coupé une première fois je vais couper
mais pas grave elle attend pas les
prénoms c'est gaston gaston alaux gaston
c'est formidable parce que moi je
voulais le garder
j'ai toujours eu du succès à l'école
avec gaza à chaque fois on me disait
comment comment tu t'appelles gaston
poussins faisait marrer tout le monde
oblige était le copain tout le monde
mais prenez pas mal quoi qui t'appelle
encore gaston personnes ainsi 6 mai
atteint mais ma femme avant mais mes
copains intime ceux qui m'ont connu
depuis le début ils m'appellent pas une
rico alors ton premier souvenir c'était
rue biscarra à constantine non oui c'est
ça globus carraway y avait des
catholiques y avait des juifs et des
musulmans
on voit qu'ils vivaient ensemble sans
beaucoup de problèmes à l'époque là bas
oui surtout que moi je suis né dans un
quartier il faut dire que à constantine
avait trois quartiers bien distincts le
quartier juif le quartier chrétien
quartier musulman mais moi je suis né
dans un quartier où toutes les
communautés étaient réunis alors il n'y
avait pas du tout de problème tant
premier chaque dans la vie c'était quoi
la guerre d'algérie c'est sûr mais le
premier attentat et tout ça le les
bombes de ça ça ça me tue et ça c'est un
truc imac qui m'a profondément choqué
parce que j'ai pas eu de jeunesse de
l'enfance on est passé directement aux
épreuves aux responsabilités ta première
guitare
je me rappelle quand j'étais tout petit
j'ai j'allais chez vous chez le
menuisier je prenais une planche et puis
avec une boîte d'allumettes
et puis des élastiques j'arrivais à
faire un petit instrument mais mon
premier instrument m'a été offert
pendant ma grand-mère et ça je
n'oublierai jamais et c'est fou de toi
tes grands parents
ah oui et moi j'étais fou mais grand
pardon tu avais 12 ans étant premier
amour c'est suzy ma femme mais ouais
elle t'a abordés par les caves et des
nattes avec des petits noirs
boudine at elle été abordé dans l'alto
tu avais honte d'être en culottes
courtes c'est vrai ça oui c'est à dire
que comme j'étais un peu trapu et non
c'est non mais moi je me rappelle de
suzy quand on était petits c'était si
t'es pas elle qui m'a abordé ces thèmes
qui ramait pour le prologue pour la r&d
parce que pour qu'elle ait dit oui j'ai
mis du temps
alors ton premier voyage en france et
s'est passé comment c'est ton père
voulait te mettre dans une école juive
traditionnelle en france l'oréal était
resté dix minutes comment ça s'est passé
je crois que tu es au courant beaucoup
tiré sais pas non c'est vrai c'est une
aubaine extraordinaire un jour je dis à
mon père papa il ya plus de professeurs
c'est la guerre et où il n'y a pas un
moyen de partir j'ai une bourse je peux
avoir une bourse devrait continuer mes
études en france là au moins je pourrai
avoir des diplômes et tout et puis
j'arrive à le convaincre
c'était la maman ma première la première
fois que j'arrivais à convaincre mon
père et ma mère surtout mon père qui
était un peu dur avec moi mais enfin je
ne regrette pas maintenant le temps
passe et que je nous les gardes et voilà
que j'arrive donc il m'a inscrit dans
une école juive puis j'arrive je suis
reçue par la directrice de l'école puis
elle me dit comment vous appelez jeudi
ghrenassia gaston tu saches que je viens
de constantine est dit et vous n'avez
pas la kippa philippe pourquoi il faut
une kippa pour venir à la synagogue
elle me dit
il faut une kippa je suis plus retourné
et là tu es allé au lycée carnot à
fontainebleau oui j'avais un cousin qui
était
étudiant à l'époque et j'ai c'était un
de mes seuls parents avec ma tante la
soeur de mon père et je lui ai dit il
faut que tu me trouves une école parce
que je vais être obligé de retourner à
constantine et ça je ne veux pas dans
une boîte a découvert le racing c'est
vrai un jour un type qui étaient dix
mois les juifs premier jour je suis
arrivée je les prie en plein dans la
gueule c'était un
un élève com - pensionnaires il
s'appelait de la masse vous rappellerai
tout tout le temps et on m'a pris pour
un musulman pour un algérien de là bas
comme je suis bronzé j'ai le type j'ai
pas le type suédois influer le regarde
comme ça tu me dis attention à moi j'ai
rien contre les arabes mais par contre
une race que je ne supporte pas c'est
les juifs
je lui ai donné un coup de poing mais
voilà au conseil de discipline ne
voulait pas dans le dans le club du
lycée de fontainebleau
il faisait un peu la gueule je voulais
pas trop et puis un jour il ya un décor
s'est effondré et a commencé à jouer
comme ça c'est vrai ça oui c'est vrai
c'est une pièce de de prévert puis moi
jouer leur le rôle d'un capitaine et
j'avais une phrase un mot à dire en
avant il a dit virer sortait j'ai pas
réussi à jeudi quand même il faut que je
fasse quelque chose
j'ai dit je le savais je chante et je
joue de la guitare alors je lui ai
chanté une chanson de mme aubry que
veut-il mais qu'est ce que c'est ça
allait non non ça n'a pas marché avant
il a fallu que à la fête du lycée de
fontainebleau j'ai une chance inouïe
le décor de la pièce qui s'effondre
ouais et pour meubler hymne appel
d'urgence je vais chercher ma guitare au
lycée et j'ai meublé j'ai chanté des
chansons je dois dire que j'ai pas eu
tellement de succès mais ça m'a donné le
goût des planches et c'est comme ça que
je suis devenu chanteur mais c'est vrai
qu'il faisait le mur à fontainebleau
pour aller jouer dans des cabarets que
vous venez de voir exactement ne pas
reconnaître quand ils n'ont non c'est
pas ça c'est que j'avais trouvé une
astuce je chantais masqué sur une
gondole la scène c'était une gondole et
je disais que j'étais un chanteur de
venise enrico je m'appelais
et sa guitare aujourd'hui est terrible
oui c'était très bien mais personne ne
me reconnaissez les premiers flirts
savait que suzy à ban avec suzy puis par
la suite on a eu d'autres expériences
quand même j'espère justement la
première fois que j'ai fait l'amour
c'était avec suzy non c'est avec qui tu
t'en souviens
oui c'était une je me rappelle ces
terres fontainebleau et c'était vraiment
la madone du tout le lycée je crois que
tous les lycées il est passé il sans
doute et en plus c'était facile elle
était nettement plus vieille que nous
c'était notre madone ta première cuite
tu t'en souviens
oui c'était aussi au 17 mars d'ailleurs
d'aider pas venu pour rien alors je
n'étais pas venu pour ton premier jour
j'ai fumé un joint une fois dans la vie
c'est au canada que j'étais avec avec
plein de copains et puis un jour je me
suis trouvé seul dans la chambre et le
mon copain devait donner un
un joint mais pour fumer avec 30
personnes moi j'ai fumé pourquoi je vous
raconte fabienne étages et et ça m'a
dégoûté pour que la ville pour toute la
vie une premier disque était acheté le
premier disque que j'ai acheté c'est
celui de mon beau père parce qu'il faut
que je vous dise que
mon père et mon beau père avait un
magasin de disques où il pouvait être
très très très riche en vendant les
disques de tout le monde
il vend dès que les disques de leur
orchestre
et donc les premiers disent que j'ai eu
c'est spécialement pour paris c'est une
des premières fois valentina alors vous
faites le sampler à ma place
d'ailleurs alors c'est la première fois
qu'on se voit on va faire une interview
première fois où est ce que vous vous
souvenez de votre premier noël
non bonsoir celui de votre premier objet
fétiche
non salut bande de nazes est ce que vous
vous souvenez de votre premier péché ah
ça oui c'était quoi
jamais jamais c'était bien adapté le
premier amour c'était tout de suite bien
ah oui c'était d'accord donc j'ai pas
besoin de demander le premier flirt le
premier baiser le premier homme parce
que dès le premier amour c'était réglé
ah ouais il a pris un mot c'était bon
oui nous ont gardé un bon souvenir
un très bon ça m'a aidé pour après elle
est sexy c'est devant tina ça vous dit
de moitié mais moi je vous comme ça
serge on peut pas mosaïque et thierry
vous l'avez jamais loin vous êtes sûr
thierry mosaïque et oui mais c'est les
choses indiqué pour ses modalités que
cherchait à échapper à la mort
mais comme ça que vous avez comme ça bon
comment ça va je prétends avoir célébré
avec plaisir avec
[Applaudissements]
on bouge pas on va voir comment senna
lenval refaire on rallume
non j'en ai vu qu ont bougé est-ce qu'on
peut rallumer
voilà la tension pendant le single on ne
bouge pas leur attention
1 2 3
tu
le premier souvenir
un souvenir avec mon grand père je dois
avoir 3 ans et demi et je suis cachée
sous une table ronde où il ya un trou et
je pique du saucisson à travers ce
rigolo
le petit chat est le symbole ipsey c'est
rigolo on est le père de jane votre
premier choc dans la vie votre premier
choc brutal mais revers
je dirais sûrement la mort de mon grand
père qui est intervenu très peu de temps
ça a été accepté la mort c'est sur la
loi de mon grand père qui est à une
journée différente
c'est sa première baffe mais parlons
jamais ni paf j'ai juste mon père qui
m'a mis un poing dans la gueule on perd
mais c'était en fait on joue à mike
tyson sur l'île j'en ai décroché le
calme et 2 secondes et il a regardé par
terre et j'ai senti que ça n'allait pas
trop bien et je lui dis pardon pas
tournée s'est retournée chez moi c'est
ça a cédé doillon ou jamais de dire
pardon papounet venions du doigt le
premier objet fétiche mon singe j'avais
un singe en réseau
non non info ma maman elle a toujours eu
un singe en peluche évidemment qu'en
chine il m'a donné un singe et moi
j'avais un singe lui arracher l'oeil
quand j'étais tout petit et je l'appelle
incarne un escroc un singe est le
premier de pêcher je crois que c'est
quand j'ai dû
ouais un jour j'ai piqué sont mal à ma
mère quand j'étais tout petit pour aller
acheter plein bonbons avec une copine je
crois c'est une première comme les
gagnants dans les rues oui j'ai fait
vous aussi ça sic et d'argent jamais
appelée maman votre nom votre premier
amour ça va c'est le fisc la meilleure
mine maman qui s'appelait harry dangers
communs comme est amoureux tout tout
petit à 6 ans ont été incendiés sur la
plage et il m'a dit d'ailleurs à six
mois ce que je trouve assez drôle je
faisais du chantage toute la journée où
je me cachais avec lui et si mon bras
sais pas je jure l'est jeu mettait à
hurler plus personne pour une 15e
m'embrasse première cuite
rêvons ennemis 14 en tout 13 ans et demi
j'habitais dans les caraïbes quand j'ai
13 ans et moins bonne saison donc
kamikazes est ce que c'est que je me
rappelle plus que c'est un fait ça c'est
la tradition gaz bourg les cocktails le
kamikaze est votre 1er juin
la même époque après qu'ils ont été bien
ce voyage pas cher ça existait deux ans
à saint barthélemy assez chouette sa
partie est votre première ex tard pas
c'est chouette ça dépend de la les
attend dirigerait je crois que je n'ai
jamais pris sauf peut-être une fois on a
filé dans un verre parce que je crois
que j'étais plus excité que j'aurais que
j'aurais été en buvant un verre quoi je
cours est un peu dans tous les sens donc
là j'ai cru profond de mika clos dans le
vert -à vous pensez que vous avez pris
avec ce tas à votre insu de ce qu'on a
mis dans ma tête je sais pas mais je
sais juste que j'ai couru dans tous les
sens pour 1 6 7 9 la veille deux étapes
du tour de france c'était la première
fois la preuve l'interview première fois
et tout le monde vous a trouvé
formidable on ne bouge pas
[Musique]
elle a bougé vous avez bougé là on
recommence aura d attention je vais vous
faire une interview première fois
[Musique]
elle peut pas s'empêcher de vous est
craquante approche m'ont inscrit à vous
est tough craquante bien premier
souvenir
bonjour j'ai rencontré jean françois
lamour guadeloupe
il est venu en plus en guadeloupe après
la télé vous avez allaité lille est venu
vraiment aussi j'ai rencontré l'amour
c'est un jour il m'a signé le premier
autographe
ouais c'est grand souvenir c'est vrai a
décidé de votre vie premier péché dit la
vérité ici on dit la vérité c'est pas
comme d'habitude à la télé ici on dit la
vérité
j'avais plus que les bonbons de mon
frère et j'avais juré que c'était pas
moi je m'attendais à un prix beaucoup
plus hard
ces premiers essais le premier bon
deuxième à la première idole jean
françois lamour ont fait dire oui
c'était pas d'amour non c'était carl
lewis à carl lewis est vrai premier
amour mauvais souvenirs à vent mauvais
souvenir non c'est un escrimeur à
c'était un escrimeur et j'en ris encore
dans les films normalement tu devrais
dire il tirait mal c'est vrai ce que tu
fous merde moi bon premier flirt
il tirait mal non plus le même ouais
premier rhum premier amour premiers
flirts premier homme c'est le même
l'escrimeur zéro pointé c'est ça qui
s'appelait alors ah oui
ce mois encore ces masses est votre
première cuite
je l'attends toujours heureusement peur
du lendemain donc je ramène plutôt que
je veux un bon votre 1er juin pas encore
vous êtes tout à découvrir attendait
mais c'est le faut regarder quel âge tu
t'en de 8 ans oui premier dopage et
j'envisage pas ah bon vous droguez pas
vous non pour le moment je savais
comment fonctionnera comment pour
l'ex-champion du monde sans vous dopez
mons entraînant et en croyant en étant
entouré par une bonne
pendant de bonnes personnes comme ça
c'est beau surtout quand je suis
passionné donc oui ça s'applaudit ça
change mais montre sans lui ont valu
bien connu c'est la première fois qu'on
se voie je vous faire une interview
première fois
[Applaudissements]
à
voilà stress un jour alors fabrice votre
premier souvenir
mon premier souvenir pour les souvenirs
de votre vie voilà la question
moi je vais comprise je vais répondre
là
c'est mon premier jour d'école justement
acheter ma mère avait gardé longtemps
les jours d'école avait été terrible
voilà vous avez quitté votre maman c'est
ça le petit garçon quand sa maman bah
oui moi aussi j'ai un fils quant à ce
qui leur à l'école bonne première balle
donc vous avez reçue à peut-être le même
jour à 9 heures je le vends un coup de
poing vous avez donné donné au passé je
pense que tout le monde à l'école mais
bon à 10 ans j'ai commencé la boxe nan
là c'était vrai à 12 ans mais d'accord
donc la seule à vraiment j'avais le
droit
votre premier péché ont dépêché les
premiers j'en suis à plus trop longue la
tendance faisant comme tout le monde ça
va les filles 14 ans non mais bon baiser
salé célébration de la vie ça
bon écoute poule ses péchés ou pas les
poules et lapins c'est de savoir le tome
i idol provenir idol aux battues pense
que quand j'ai commencé la boxe moi
j'aime bien même un boxeur que j'aimais
bien que je crois si vous le connaissez
mais j'étais de marvin hagler wenger ou
balade entre un boxeur du boxer croisé
voilà maintenant même si on s'intéresse
un peu à la boxe on connaît la tuerie
c'est comme si vous aviez dit je
voudrais être que si célèbre qu'elle
font ses voeux halimi qu'on parle de moi
comme d'alphonse halimi non je voulais
jeune homme passionné ça il ya un rambo
crown un problème toujours en habitant
l'an 2000 et en parle toujours des
anciens boxeurs way et ça c'est bon ils
ont fait quelque chose j'aime bien tout
ça mais maintenant je veux dire fou qui
faut qu'on arrête de parler autant de
millions voire et donc c'est ce que je
dis maintenant si je voulais vous dire
je veux laisser une trace dans la boxe
comme le cerveau ou allez me l'ont fait
c'est vrai vous avez raison c'est vrai
qu'il ya 30 40 50 ans les boxeurs cerdan
aussi une énorme star quoi et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui vous double champion du
monde pourrait être connue bien sûr
votre nom est connu mais voter dans vos
systar que ça ouais ouais voilà donc
mais avec une catégorie aussi savaient
beaucoup moins de 4 go mais disons que
celles annoncées en avant les boks en
avant ne pourrait pas gagner maintenant
j'ai dansé des comparaisons qui sont qui
sont pas possibles
ses dernières toiles
la méditation votre premier amour non
souvenirs amour à 14 ans j'ai rencontré
ma femme de maintenant
je vous demande pas votre première
expérience sexuelle c'est complètement
la main c'est fou il ya eu tromperie
entre tanger mais pas du tout ça veut
dire c'est que c'est possible c'est
possible les avocats spéciaux dont c'est
un don du ciel
non mais une femme dans une vie un ça va
c'est extraordinaire franchement c'est
arrivé à mes parents mais j'avais 18 ans
votre première cuite s'en souvenait oui
à 11 ans j'ai fait exprès pour dire
voilà bonjour j'ai pris une cuite et
vous en avez pris d'autres après quand
même non quelques-unes de quelques-unes
le 1er juin
quinze ans ça vous a pas bon du tout
j'ai déjà reçu plusieurs fois mais c'est
pas notre truc est votre premier de
dopage ne voit presque pas les boxeurs
bon moi c'est toujours ce que je réponds
je dis donc s'il y en a peut-être enfin
c'est pas ce domaine donc il n'ya pas
une piqûre on est un médicament qui peut
faire qu'on ait un viseur conseil
soumettre le coup et où il n'ya pas de
piqûre ou médicaments pareil qui font
qu'ils sont les couples usa prague
bon c'est pas possible voilà donc si
vous avez un merci beaucoup
internet a une première fois en baisse
la lumière on ne bouge pas par le single
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui j'ai donné l'exemple oui j'ai mal
agi mais je comprends pas bien intérêt
ouais c'est vrai ça remarque ça évite de
geler l'image
il avait des petits moyens mais déjà je
newton à ses premiers souvenirs premier
souvenir est votre premier souvenir de
votre vie c'est dur ça c'est normal on
est vu des jeunes bretons réjouir non ce
n'est pas donc si ça c'est sa relation
sexuelle ah bon vous assez ça vous allez
trouver leur joie vous êtes la mouna oui
et c'était vous souvenez c'est pas très
bien dans une cage d'escalier d'un
ascenseur
les ascenseurs quand on est quand on ne
fait pas exprès je veux dire c'est
beaucoup moins drôle c'est vrai votre
premier objet fétiche
tu peux pas le dire dans l'ascenseur
aussi vraiment oui le premier péché le
vol le vol
ouais vous souvenez ce que c'était c'est
le porte-monnaie de votre mère au début
non non il a piqué un ballon et personne
l'a rattrapé par ses petites voitures le
bras ouais petites voitures dans des
boutiques web votre premier jour à
l'école vous en souvenez
très difficile ouais et le premier jour
au stade français je me suis demandé ce
que je fais là j'ai eu beaucoup de
nouvelles têtes renouvelle entraîneur
nouvelle président je me suis dit j'ai
peut-être pas fils le meilleur choix le
premier rideau hall enrico c'était qui
ma première idéale vous maintenant
madonna a dit dont madonna votre mari
vous en a voulu
ah oui je sors de madonna connaissez pas
l'histoire quand il prit madonna justify
my love c'était votre mari touristes une
chanson très non mais à la fin vous
savez ce qu'elle a dit non ce qu'on peut
dire ça la telline français on peut tout
dire dans cette émission on peut tout
dire à la fin des facs oui oui mon ex
mari était en train de prier alors il se
lève il prend le cv il le jette pas la
faire en disant je ne veux plus jamais
entendre parler de cette femme chez moi
à oui les vannes rigau qui passait en
twingo
c'était à éviter l'accident de et j'ai
évacué évacue premier flirt
ça vous a pas laissé un souvenir
impérissable
[Rires]
je vais lui parler
oui non non je me souviens la première
fois avec une fille vous en souvenez là
oui bon d'accord
eric un garçon
c'est la grande très très mal passé je
suis mal passé très vous avez pu
recommencer donc les îles une fois quand
même ouais c'est bien il faut essayer
presse appelait ça fait pas mal je
plaisantais il est jamais essayé
d'amener cette botte qui va maintenant
vous avez vous jamais eu envie d'essayer
d'en haut c'est marrant ça commence à
essayer way s'est bien passé non mais
j'ai essayé d'accord et la première fois
à plusieurs reprises mais oui et alors
sympathique tussauds salue la balle de
trucs sympas même année il ya eu tôt
fait de vous son visage s'est illuminé
mais combien de filles comme garçons
doivent être maintenant chez nietzsche
trois garçons et deux filles espagne
ouais bah voilà canal c'est tous les
jours noël ou un canal quand on
fréquente comme gildas à 121 première
cuite douloureuse douloureuse pastis oui
nivet pastis et un du rose et du pastis
pays connaissait un tricot à saint
tropez l'été et non regarde le 1er juin
la mort 10h30 17h à vous a laissé un
souvenir impérissable
oui très mauvais ah bon vous ai plus
jamais recommencer
non il a marqué contre son sac vous êtes
international de rugby certainement je
me disais aussi première ecstasy jamais
jamais pour ça que vous êtes
international diori mis six premiers
millions pas encore pas encore voulait
pas toucher aux dalles quelques leçons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bastien
[Applaudissements]
bah oui vraiment génome va manger comme
ça a été très sympathique que je voulais
je vais faire un petit cadeau
ouais c'est le nouvel hymne du stade
français ah ouais life is so strong aaa
[Applaudissements]
avant c'était wilson c'est vous qui avez
passé le stade français c'est qu'elle
est relancé à will survive et ça c'est
un original sa wii va très bien merci
beaucoup de coutras en pensant à vous
merci que l'esclave dominici avec douche
et révélant le match
le truc de monsieur spock portait
première baffe jeune très jeune je sais
pas c'était une baffe ou une droite si
c'était une base c'était peut-être vos
parents c'était une droite s'était pas
vos parents ou mon frère ou way notre
frère premiers désirs première fois que
vous avez éprouver du désir pour
quelqu'un ou non une paire de baskets
sûrement à huy premier amour mais je le
cherche encore à quai ici alors on a
fait ce qu'il faut savoir quand même
bien le folie on veut quand même là on
peut guère faire plus et aussi monsieur
cayla qui espère bien il fallait habiter
dans le larzac en même temps premières
organiques encore la paire de baskets et
questionner la paire de baskets premiers
tags vous étiez tagueurs avant way band
sur la rue blanche très très tôt ouais
regard que l'âge je sais pas de 14 ans
et vous taguer quoi c'est très compliqué
mais en tongs et beaucoup mais je suis
bien dire chaussée des dessins s'adresse
à commencer par le tag pur et dur et
puis après c'est parti vers la peinture
plus plu soit des fresques et c est ce
qu on appellera et grafite et purs et
durs et vêtements premier cachet
d'aspirine
je suis bonne réponse premier voyage
maroc voir la famille quand on était
petit première cuite tard hyper tarde
d'arriver de l'alcool vous pas vraiment
l'enjeu boit du vin est ce que vous êtes
un musulman est ce que vous êtes
musulman pratiquant musulman merci parce
qu'on a eue si djamel bouras ont été
très étonné parce que là aussi c'est un
truc était très souvent été très étonné
c'est un musulman qui revendiquait sa
religion mais jeune moderne tout qui
revendiquait sa religion la télévision
et on s'est aperçu en écoutant djamel
bouras que finalement il était très rare
aussi ça faisait des cathos qui viennent
des juifs qui viennent par et de la
religion mais musulmans nés
j'étais très étonnée vous vous êtes
musulman pratiquant vêtements musulmans
pratiquants de père de mère et de
traditions vous faites comme nous avec
le préservatif si vous buvez un petit
couteau d'antan ouais 1er juin n'ont pas
toujours pas de juin non à part les
vacances fin juin premières lignes rer b
olona gardienne laura l'uimm serge la
lumière on ne bouge pas pendant dix ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui j'ai et verbale a dit oh non non non
non les douaisiens jugé l'été un facile
c'est pas bougé il faut qu'on ait aussi
on recommence on rallume la lumière à
cause des douleurs à la prudence et pas
à cause des douars c'est à cause des
manuels attention un deux trois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
réussi celui-là edward wright est impec
on me dit dans l'oreillette que c'était
un exe pas oublier vous non plus non
alors emmanuel comme c'est la première
fois qu'on se voir me faire une table
une première fois ça sert encore à moi
oui premier souvenir
votre premier souvenir quand j'ai
embrassé un garçon derrière le
préfabriqué à couvrir j'avais trois ans
très précoce à la deuxième question
c'était premiers désirs mais j'ose pas
vous la posez pas ce que c'était mais là
c'était le même c'était le même premier
rendez vous amoureux c'est encore le
meriva oui je me sens mieux pêcher
c'était le même j'avais en empêcher
n'essayez pas de détourner la question
emmanuel premier match avoue que c'était
le même église
c'était dans une église ou gendre à ses
rejets mais avec la longue avec l'âne
antirabique ou de foot c'était roger
première passion c'était roger médisance
et rouge est quand même il a du pauvre
et premier réveil à deux ce n'est pas
roger quand même réveil à deux premières
fois vous êtes réveillé à deux avec un
garçon dans un lit eh bien c'était au
pensionnat de maisons laffitte 1 et je
me suis endormi et voilà c'était je me
suis dit ah oui c'était je ne s'est
réveillé dans l'internât des garçons
c'est très bien prenez week-end à 2
alors que les autres c'était la première
premier week end à deux c'était avec
roger et wii party en angleterre où est
saturé vachement posé leur premier
chagrin d'amour c'est roger edwards
edwards
je me pose est d'avoir osé non non c'est
que pour vous mais rejet là il veut
expliquer que c'est pas lui
non mais bien sûr malgré un levier ce
qu'il écrit en effet malgré ce qu'il
écrit il faut voir ce qu'il est sans
roger roger ce formidable après j'ai
cessé mes doigts reprise de
l'entraînement mais c'est ailleurs les a
réunis ce soir
donc voilà
devoir accompli d'abord j'ai ensuite
edouard très bien donc première map où
tout ça c'est du roger chagrin d'amour
c'est roger aussi je sais pas j'en aurai
tout le temps ah ouais j'avais à nez en
trompette des taches de rousseur et ils
m'ont tous abandonné donc j tout les
mecs tout le terreau s'aggrave un bureau
permanent première rupture
j'avais 4 ans quatre ans c'est jeune je
venais de me marier
ouais devant un arbre ah oui oui on lui
dit j'aurais aimé vous connaître à coup
j'ai divorcé un premier divorce c'est
toujours pareil quoi c'est un témoignage
c'est là qu'on fait entre trois et
quatre ans emmanuelle béart a vécu tout
ce que nous on a mis 40 ou 50 ans aviv
quoi première envie de vous suicider
première envie de me suicider j'avais
six mois moi je me rappelle pas j'ai eu
envie quand même oui messieurs comme
tout le monde j'imagine
j'ai pas eu envie de me suicider ou moi
mais j'étais plus vieux j'avais 32 ans
et qu'est ce qui vous était arrivé
chagrin d'amour c'est classique un bond
au nom auquel sentimentale
bon et noir j'ai su que j de vous poser
la question à vous aussi est ce que vous
avez envie de vous suicider une fois
dans votre beau tout le monde en a envie
géré comme un emmanuel hubert 95 comme
[Applaudissements]
ça n'était pas assez important pour ça
très bien bonne réponse en allume la
lumière comme c'est votre premier roman
on va faire une interview première fois
on bouge pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va bouger vous avez punis est ce
qu'on peut apporter le martinet qu'on a
acheté à pigalle la finition c'est une
interview première fois moi d'abord la
reddition sa nouvelle fois vous allez
répondre franchement j'avais essayé
premiers désirs littéraire j'ai dit
franchement
ben oui mais pas ça peut très bien être
par les livres oui c'est vrai petit
baiser premier baiser c'est une chanson
un peu guimauve dont je me souviens plus
là mais je connais la chanson en
revanche vous souvenez vous de votre
premier baiser
s'ils sont conventionnées avec une
copine jennifer jennifer on ne monte pas
à thierry je connais bien il a été pêché
des curés alors il sait comment ça va
s'arrêter là mais moi j'aime embrasser
la vérité c'est long très tard en fait
c'est à vous donner de la première fois
oui bien sûr et alors très bien il
savait pas eu l'oeil et le bon dieu ni
le ulf la première à noah sort gagnant
mais une première passion la littérature
non mais c'est vrai parce que c'est vrai
que le livre m'a sauvé la sauver de
beaucoup de choses et m'a aidé à me
construire première nuit à deux avec
vous après ces après émission quatre ses
mains partout moi est ce que vous vous
souvenez de la première nuit à 2 1 + 1
c'est ça non ben non de martine eu des
larmes pour un garçon j'ai pas pu ré un
bon c'est ça les asiatiques première
rupture
à 22 ans
c'était dur c'est toujours dire vous
êtes remis ça
votre première vraie transgression
sexuelle à a3 en 1re div
c'est sa première fois à plusieurs je ne
dis rien je ne veux pas que ça qu'on
sache c'est peut-être c'est peut-être là
en ce moment parce que je livre beaucoup
je me serai habillé un première fois
avec une fille jamais je vous êtes un
écrivain est par essence mans cedex
chose on m'avait dit on m'avait lycée
tival son jeu vous faire une interview
première fois on ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bond inattendu première fois c'est
facile hein voilà la première fois la
wii mais après leur faux fait la
première fois vous trouvez souvenir mon
premier souvenir de quoi de votre vie la
mienne dit d'armand oui effectivement
votre premier souvenir vous étiez tout
petit petit petit petit je me souviens
que j'étais amoureuse d'un garçon en
maternelle qui ressemblait beaucoup au
prince dont est amoureuse quand diviser
le dessin animé et moi j'étais amoureuse
du prince donnerais tu es amoureux ce
qu'en dit parce que j'étais un peu comme
candy est donc ce petit garçon la
maternelle qui était réelle ressemble
beaucoup à ce garçon que ça plus antonio
être comme ça et donc j'étais absolument
à -11 lui c'était fou mais j'avais mes
meilleures amies quête amoureuse lui
aussi est donc on l'est courrait après
toutes les deux comme des hystériques
d'un de maternelle et on lui montrait un
petite culotte tout ça
ça commence fort votre premier péché
péché oui c'est génial a pas péché
mortel
mon premier péché
le premier est de l'avis de gérard de la
sienne de la vie de sophie le premier
péché mon premier péché mais j'ai pas
vous le dire
voici maintenant c'est un truc ouais
hein
tout sonne donc bon on a compris votre
premier amour donc si je l'avais dit
c'était le petit anthony la leur face
qui ressemble au prince quoi si on
appelle ça un amour mais après il ya
votre premier amour amour quoi ouais
c'était qui disent le nom le prénom et
son nom qui s'était même je vous dit pas
le nom et le prénom c'est un mec
ouais ça s'appelle 30 lyon dès
l'accouchement m appeler difficile mais
on va y arriver
non mais bon un mec d'accord mais à part
ça quoi ça c'est quel âge vous aviez 15
ans à 15 ans deux premières manches de
15 en quoi c'est trop tard
moi je trouve ça un peu tard non quant à
16 ans moi j'attends d'une vraie
histoire je parle pas des petites
amourettes oui d'accord d'accord
bon disons 6 à 15 ans que tout ça s'est
passé quoi ah ouais bah voilà première
fois à trois 3 ans à 3 jeudi
quand on était à 2 c 15 ans à 15h30 d'un
seul coup d'un seul coup on va passer à
15h30 avoue gérard dans la première fois
doit céder quand dans les années 70 moi
j'aime mais moi je ne réponds pas ses
interviews la pression mission vandaele
sont là bien
tiens donc on a traversé les années
soixante dix première fois trois
preneurs pas avec 4 voilà c'est à peu
près le même parcours que le vôtre tant
mieux pour vous à la première fois à
capcom premier chagrin d'amour donc oui
donc c'est celui où les gâteaux baby
sitter voile à dakar j'ai compris de 10
kg d'accord ok j'ai compris première
tentative de suicide la sagem
pourquoi vous ai jamais ici de vous
suicider annoncé samedi que le nutella
satuc en bon madame de fontenay natation
va catherine ce serait bien qu'on
réinvite mal de fautes mais ça fait
longtemps voilà bavure c'est quand tu
veux me dit catherine dans l'oreillette
merci qu'elle avait entre deux gendarmes
pour nos inquiétudes
alors bon premier première cuite je sais
pas vers 16 17
c'est avec le premier l'a tout chercher
ensemble bien mon bonbon n'ont pas de
match quand tu es demandé sa première
cuite il m'a dit je m'en souviens pas
j'ai dit pourquoi il va jeter bourg
premier pétard la rue c'était un bon
c'était la bonne époque j'étais là il
fallait vous connaître en fait première
ligne jamais non jamais très bien c'est
bien vous avez raison
première chose que vous faites le matin
en vous réveillant à pisser c'est que je
me bats les couilles s'agit pas du tout
votre dernière volonté si vous deviez
mourir pis ses dernières volontés si
vous deviez mourir
tout le monde bouge dans le gym importe
quoi votre premier souvenir vous
souvenez de votre premier souvenir alors
jeunesse quand j'étais déguisé en fait à
l'école vos premiers chocs
mon premier choc tu t'es vue on fait
quand t'es quoi quand tu t'es vu en fait
peut-être quand on m'a transformé quand
j'ai transformé quelqu'un avec la
baguette
non mais parce qu'elle passe que she
loves you very much non y'a un petit
délai il ya un petit délit chaque quand
tu dis quelque chose le temps qu'on
traduise et où qu'elles se marre de me
la faire
je dirais oui c'est ce qui vient dire
prévisions qu'est-ce qui viennent mais
votre premier péché ça vous vous en
souvenez vous est-ce que c'était un
péché j'ai coupé les cheveux d'une fille
enfin c'est peu c'est pas empêcher ça
serait trop vieille trop joli ça
simplement parce qu'elle allait
appliquer un
un mec à la wii non ça c'est un pitch
est simple c'est lui a carrément un
péché s'est pressée cheveux coupés
dites moi votre votre votre premier
amour wee aa
c'est une belle sandrine ça lui rappelle
cette chanson c'est vrai ça vous
rappelle que premièrement oui et là elle
a du mal à lui à l'air de rien elle
sourit et on m pour sa ligne c'est
quelque chose de très très dur de craie
on peux plus écouter cette chanson très
très fort là elle sourit parce qu'elle
est forte
c'est vous qui l'avait larguée oui parce
qu'ils viennent à l'argot siens on est
tombé sur une base est simple c'est
l'art qui disent non vous êtes d'europe
centrale toutes les deux ou trois points
comme elle s'appelle céline tchèque
oui c'est vrai non vous avez l'un des
deux points communs vous êtes d'europe
centrale toutes les deux vous êtes des
pays en fait de décommander mon premier
livre dans les idées china non non non
et je sais plus qui parle tu peux lui
demander une adresse web c'est sympa
mais madame
photo paraisse que la madame première
cuite
oui un réveillon de nouvel an il ya
longtemps bien longtemps
ouais avec ma soeur premier pétard
jamais non pas une taffe comme clinton
et ça m'a fait cracher la fumée voilà
ouais t'as rien dit c'est ça votre
première chance dans la vie qui vous la
donner je pense que ce sont mes parents
premier échec c'est quoi première
tchèque
ça pue
que je bois je veux pas te perdre c'est
sympa mais je te regarde à la télé
non je dirais l'irrésolu parce que c'est
vraiment un film que j'aime pas ah oui
et la première chose que vous faites le
matin vous réveillant je vais voir ma
fille je ne bouge pas pendant le single
[Musique]
mellick n'a pas bougé par le dynamo je
vais dire allez vous êtes bien quand
même
pourtant il est rapide quant à judith
elle peut pas s'empêcher de bouger bien
alors combien souligné souvenirs à part
le normand je crois oui c'est la
première fois que que j'ai vu de la
neige j'étais tout petit et samassa m'a
choqué et ce qui m'a le plus marqué
c'est que j'ai dit à ma mère regarde
maman il pleut de la purée hélas non
c'est vrai et la maladie ce nuage qui va
être très con
premier choc abreu me choque c'est quand
comme mon père m'a appris que les
village people était homosexuel ouais
moi c'est quand les beatles se sont
séparés il est homosexuel
non mais cette salade de yoko ono j'en
veux premier mensonge
premier mensonge e journée j'en ai
beaucoup des mensonges
je suis pas seul plaisir jacques je
voudrais vous faire un grand compliment
au moins pour les choses avec
philosophie
ça c'est un an dernier mensonge premier
baiser avec la langue
bah premier baiser c'est une fille qui
s'appelait nique puis elle tourner la
langue trop vite oui et en plus à
l'ouvré pas la bouche ça servira
première fois première fois deux dans un
camping avec une belge première fois à
troyes jamais hélas ni et les allemands
non copine de me demander à l'interné
france 2 l'an
jamais classe regardez votre caméra et
lance un appel tout de suite c'est à ça
que ça sert la télé je recherche une
nounou lors deux deux nounous non une
j'en ai déjà une wii j'ai déjà ma nounou
une deuxième nous nous tout est accepté
ouais bien vous pensé parce qu'à partir
harmos avantage mais c'est là alors
c'est là vous êtes vraiment un mec c'est
à dire que quand vous pensez à faire
l'amour à trois vous pensez tout de
suite que la personne supplémentaire
sera une fille et pas un garçon très
sympa pour vous pour votre fiancée ouais
mais nancy on faisait l'amour à trois
avec un mec moi j'aurais vraiment
l'impression de faire l'amour avec le
mec et j'ai pas envie de voir son machin
qui ballotte ça m'intéresse maintenant
tu seras d'autres grands rien qu'elle
s'est mariée m vous êtes tous les mêmes
première rupture
4 première fois c'est très peu pour
s'arracher première rupture
ça s'était très vite c'était une copine
qui est venu fera voisine qui est venu
frapper un rapport j'avais 12 ans elle
m'a dit moi il ya béatrice qui voudrait
sortir avec toi j attends faut que je
réfléchisse je suis partie au judo de
trois heures je suis revenue la même
voisine du revenu frapper alors moi
j'étais prêt à donner ma réponse
amélioré à béatrice qu'elle changeait
d'avis au sort de christophe et ses
premières ruptures gd s'est rien passé
le dans sa serre est passée ta rentrée
d'été ceinture bleue quand marie mes
premiers vrais chagrin d'amour
quand j'ai quitté ma mère pour monter à
paris
ah que c'est beau ça voulait quand j'ai
quitté ma première tentative de suicide
jamais s'est jamais eu envie de vous
suicider voir plutôt mourir non un
premier pétard
je ne veux pas de nom bon été non non
non non j'ai déjà tiré une ou deux
taffes
mais je suis pas non c'est pas mon oui
bon oui j'en ai fumé
m
[Applaudissements]
il ya déjà melnyk la première chose que
vous faites le matin au réveil
le matin au réveil j'ai beaucoup aimé
questionnaire là pour ça vous fera
peut-être pas répondu la même chose est
ce que je vais dire là par contre le
matin non non non le matin les matins je
devrai bien à temps quand les couilles
de maternelle je sais qu'il fut un gros
pet le matin le matin et là il ya des
mecs qui vont se reconnaître moi j'ai la
petite érections matinales
ouais alors alors je laisse pas passer
ça et je fais l'amour même si je suis
tout seul
bien on va rallumer vous êtes concentré
ses premiers souvenirs
ma première ivresse
ah bon cet accord c'était ça fait dix on
vous avait 22 ans
premier choc j'ai fait quand j'ai récité
une poésie dans ma classe c'était en ce2
oui et c'est à vous ça vous a plu vous
ai dit c'est ça que je veux faire non
non tu as vraiment fâché j'ai eu une
part monstrueuse que les mensonges ne
sais pas c'est pas mal le mensonge en ça
permet d'inventer une réalité meilleur
je crois que je pratique et très tôt
c'est une proche
c'est une tranche comme elles sont
jetées lady avait fait hypokhâgne ans
n'a aucune chance
premier péché ya pas de pêcher
blessé il ya mes péchés rien premières
amours il faut que je dise quoi
premièrement non vous n'êtes pas que
j'ai donné le nom l'adresse saoudite il
avait pas en voilà qu'en sais tu peux tu
petit j'imagine c'était non j'étais
passé le titre que c'était un garçon
blond avec une queue de cheval comme
sahin qui baissent à nouveau mon collège
nous étions c'est un garçon premier
baiser sur un skateboard d'une acrobate
ce qu'il était tout petit avant premier
flirt poussé gérard et ad avec la langue
et tout ça mais c'était c'était c'était
le premier de la queue de cheval
non c'était le scan bronn scpa première
idole aznavour peut-être première belle
robe
j'avais une robe en lapin comme les
amours je sais qui c'est moi c'est celui
de nantes à qui vous est venue à paris
non ouais c'est ça
et alors alors là ça devient chaud
première fois deux fois que vous avez
fait l'amour à deux avec un garçon ou
une fille première fois des ventes en
baisse et l humain merci
ah bon il faudrait que j'exerce en tire
comme ça je vais pas vous demander la
première fois à troyes parce qu'ici non
parce que ça ici on est ici on est
discret dont je demanderai pas la
première fois trois premières fois 4
jamais je n'ai pas encore essayé vous
êtes 22 en même temps première rupture
premier rupture c'était à 18 ans c'est
lui qui ronflait non il reflète je peux
vous demander à quel âge de les filmer
votre premier pétard parce que ça c'est
de la provocation facile première ligne
alors vous n'êtes pas obligé de répondre
premier succès premier succès mais c'est
lent c'est la cimade pour ça que c'est
là tout le monde c'est clair bientôt la
première la première ligne voilà
en 1re échec je le connais c'est
terminal du giro un seul et même voix la
première chose que vous faites le matin
au réveil je prends une douche le matin
moi je veux pas de douche jeu c'est un
truc que je fais c'est inconscient j'ai
vu ça dans un film c'est l'être tv ouais
je me passe la main j'ai un grand choc
mondial de foot etc et je me passe la
main mais c'est inconscient après je
vois mon café vient bien tu te tais
aucune chance aucune chance mais c'est
inconscient c'est souvent on fait sa
dernière volonté si vous deviez mourir
là maintenant c'est important dit de
venir en rouge au profit de venir à
nancy avant c'est tout c'est pas plus
chaud que ça mais c'est très chaud bush
avant merci bien
premier péché je crois pas au péché on
croyait pas empêché karine silla me
croyez pas vos péchés et puis si de tuer
oui oui c'est tout à part ça il n'y a
pas de pêcher ben je sais pas vous savez
elle n'est pas catholique comme vous
c'est peut-être pour ça oui j'ai été
élevé là dedans nous avons aussi premier
amour une dizaine d'années vient enfin
quand j'avais une dizaine d'années et
alors
la veste est oubliée non premier baiser
une cour d'école sombre dans une grande
déception
ah bon vous et que les déceptions alors
après ça va mieux premier flirt poussé à
une belle histoire à vous
enfin une belle histoire maintenant rien
faire pousser du combat poussé jeu quand
tu mets un peu la main c'est quoi
pousser pour toi jean j'ai touché c'est
bien de faire une petite bise premier
vrai amour
oui le premier flirt poussé correspond
au premier vrai amour est pas mal ah oui
ça va mieux la première rupture ça avec
lui aussi un deux jours après non non
pas deux jours quand même attendu du
fait de la peine à combien non quelques
jours après après aussi remis après on a
souffert
voilà français repoussé la première
cuite sa date de cette époque
oui oui je devais avoir une quinzaine
d'années oui je veux faire la maligne
une bonne bouteille de vodka ça me
faisait rien puis je suis tombé premier
pétard même époque
non non je fume peintres au plus tard
non oui seigneur jupiter père regarde
donc tu peux aller chercher une bière
donc fermer les volets non cette époque
premier succès j'ai pas dire ainsi c'est
triste je me faire pousser non c'est un
sujet dont on pouvait dire ça c'est un
succès c'est la première fois qu'on m'a
fait confiance et votre confiance et le
premier rôle
ces parades en tous les cas pas oui
on va vous faire pour mieux vous
connaître on va faire une interview
première fois pour
[Musique]
premier souvenir la première scène avec
notre dame peut-être ouais ouais
premier choc la première scène avec
notre dame premier mensonge la première
scène est de vous faire chier maintenant
premier amour on était tout petit
ah bon ouais ouais ça tombe sous le coup
de la loi mais voilà c'est le premier
homme c'est quoi un bisou avec la longue
ça c'est bien je vais préparer le bisou
avec la langue aussi je m'en veux de la
bouche bien bien première idole whitney
houston premier disque moi je savais
qu'ils s'étaient sénat toujours avec je
peux pas avoir prétendu vraiment avoir
travaillé avec je te dise que c'était sa
famille oui et j'ai ris de veau deuxième
disque avec avec pas si oui qu'est
d'ailleurs que sur l'album sur la balle
que la premier vrai grand amour
mais si c'est pas encore arrivé dit le
sai on est nombreux téléspectateurs qui
sont intéressés toute façon pas par
l'idée de le savoir
non je crois wes saison première cuite
avec notre dame
d'ailleurs c'était la seule et l'unique
1 parce qu'il m'a dégoûté ouais ouais
ouais c'était vomir discipline moto
j'avais gare où j'avais garé ou à gauche
a vu je suis plus à droite je me
souviens pas et puis j'ai une designeuse
y boit un petit peu il m'étonne un peu
de ricard et puis et un et deux et puis
le troisième
et là j'ai fini dans les toilettes je ne
sais plus on veut nous raconter pas
parce qu'il ya un ministre de la
république assez discret premier pétard
non jamais ah bon non ça m'a jamais il
ne m'a pas sur lui nos premiers succès
donc notre dame de paris des premiers
échecs
non l'amitié avec hélène ségara
alors ça aurait pu être une belle
histoire c'est vrai vous regrettez pas
un peu ça regretter quoi j'aurais pu
devenir amitié 2
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien wasquehal a bossé bien alors
c'est une interview première fois un
premier choc
la perte d'un de quelqu'un de la famille
c'était la grand mère de mon père et
c'est là que j'ai vu mon père pour la
première fois pleurer ça ce terrain le
premier choc premiers amours en souvenez
quand même ouais c'est jamais je crois à
trois ou quatre ans les aimera mais bien
sûr tout mais la morale à la maternelle
en cours bisous sous le préau et c'est
sa reste très très gentil
est-ce que l'histoire de votre âme et
qui vous a fait du mal ce n'était pas
l'histoire des grandes filles les autres
fouilles mais c'est un amant malsain
c'est un amour qui fait souffrir saint
amand dans lequel on s'enferme justement
c'est vous alors que vous faites un
cinoche
oui non c'est inconscient déjà les
souvenirs vers 12 13 ans c'est quelque
chose qui est très très fréquent on se
plaît à aimer quelqu'un qui vous fait
souffrir que ce soit en amour en amitié
voilà
et
c'est plein buzz et wave et ses bisous à
la maternelle
justement ce premier rame en chaîne qui
rit oui au cloud comme ça voilà remet
également que ces barques et c'était
pitoyable avoir songé nous reste comme
un beau diable
j'avais entre 12 et 13 ans je sais plus
et je me souviens non mais je me
souviens je me souviens j'étais il y
avait une petite place un arrêt de bus
et je dis au revoir à ce garçon c'était
mon premier baiser avec la langue et je
me suis retourné j'ai regardé mes
copines j'ai fait j'ai fais vraiment la
gueule
après premier falloir pousser ses
marques et le fera toucher 1
j'aimerais aussi tu t'es au mois de mai
un voyage à venise
voilà le cas l'année j'avais un beau 10
à 12 ans et demi j'avais entre j'avais
j'allais vers des 16 ans ça devrait se
faire engueuler par alonso nous c'est
pas mal
bon alors avoisiner première fois tout
ne fait que dénoncer marqué c'est une
question de la place et pas du tout le
monde
[Applaudissements]
j'arrête ma famille cela marche pas
comme ça c'est plus je sais que les mecs
et cdu la vigne et c'est parce qu'il
veut tirer
mais non je sais pas quel âge mais
j'étais tendances annoncées première
fois tout mais pas trop alors le premier
vrai amour de l'amour le vrai rencontre
est déjà le premier parce que là
plusieurs déjà pas très longtemps avant
le premier vrai amour c'est ya pas très
longtemps ça fait un an et demi
l'été il y en s'excusant était beau et
premier rupture elle a pas de rupture
pas si c'est première vraie rupture dont
je me souviens bien kim a acquis mais
romain j'ai un peu de mal à digérer
je crois que je venais d'avoir 14 ans
est ce qu'il ya une vraie rupture quand
il n'y a pas d'amour du tout mais il ya
de la mosson vie commune comme il ya non
mais cet essai de la mort c'est de
l'amour de dado c'est un truc on craque
sur quelqu'un reste avec les deux mois
et et puis voilà et puis on se rend
compte avec le temps que c'est pas c'est
pas de l'amour mais que la rupture est
toujours une rupture une vraie
souffrance
à ce moment là ouais il alors pour soi
en plus sa copine
romain je crois que nous enfoncer le
clou quand amour je demande ça pète et
la copine moi finalement tu vois pas à
le vrai amour est certainement mais sans
voilà alors c'est quoi première cuite
c'est ça au monde appelle le bernard
c'était tellement
on verra très bientôt
j'étais tellement pas bien conscient
pour traîner par les amis comme ça une
émission d'ardus si j'étais en vacances
à cholet a le choix
voilà avec mes parents et j'étais parti
avec une amie et on a rencontré deux
jeunes parisiens gonds vous trouvez
plutôt sympa et tout qu'ils voulaient
jouer au tennis et conseil ce soir on
fait la fête on ramène des bouteilles et
qui la bière et je ne sais quoi et puis
enfin je suis bien amasser 100 voilà
comment je pense qu'il vaut lui servait
parce que je le mette face aux parents
regardent
non mais ils s'aiment parce que je me
suis fait un peu choqué par maman y'a
pas que tu appartiens moment que tp show
peu ça
doit plier sur ces clauses cherche
l'appui sans m'importe quoi le faire un
accord en la bouche parking dans la
bouche pendant les dix premiers baisers
dans une boue a pendant un saut
quantique qu'elle a 13 12 c'était lui
donne sa qualité son prénom je vois si
vous ne mentez et il est là et là ce
soir
non sérieusement oui c'est bastia c'est
bien vous êtes resté cinq mois ensemble
bravo bonne réponse
alors maintenant on va passer à la
première fois tous les deux tout nu dans
un lit
vous avez quel âge s'est passé bastien
c'est un autre ce décalage
seize bravo et été et ça a duré combien
de temps deux minutes
non non non la relation relation me
raconter des histoires bravo aux jeunes
c'est bien bravo brest ont des biens de
deux ans votre premier casting
je me rappelle ces faits très anciens
c'était chez filipacchi aux champs
elysées ok magazine
jeune et jolie première idole madonna
première fois première fois à troyes
bahia enfin ya un an et demi maintenant
première fois 4
pas encore entièrement nous premier
chagrin d'amour
je n'ai pas eu vraiment bon c'est parce
que vous n'êtes pas encore aimer
vraiment peut-être
voilà ça je sais pas premier 1er juin de
cabanis j'ai cherché mon meilleur copain
mathieu g son père médecin
wen sans contrôle médical datant
première chose que vous faites le matin
en vous réveillant bien alors on va
faire une table ou première fois
moche parts dans la holding heures
mon plat pays
qui est mien reviendrait pas avec
l'accent belge d'ailière des plus beaux
jeux via chez les plus jeunes d'avoir
faire l'interview première fois mais
avec l'accent notamment
oui vraiment vous le fait vachement bien
j'ai par exemple on va nettoyer des
belges qui regarde à voile et à tous les
liégeois je vous embrasse
voilà c'est bien on avait julie snyder
noir malgré ça fait déborder une bonne
analyse
c'est exactement ce que je pense des
québécoises mois bonsoir et gilles
ménage qui est là bonsoir
alors votre premier souvenir mon premier
souvenir
l'action est à dire avec l'accent oui
premier souvenir
mon premier souvenir le sourire de ma
mère
non voilà je peux pas dire ça mais pas
comme ça
pourquoi quoique sans le sourire de ma
mère c'est beaucoup mieux déjà premier
choc de votre vie moi quand j'ai appris
que le père noël n'existait pas
c'est à dire moi quand j'ai appris que
le père noël n'existait pas j'ai été
vraiment choqués non mais c'est vrai oui
mais ça refroidit tout le monde sur
l'accord des jolies filles comme ça et
ça tu sais je ne veux plus c'est
pourquoi il c'est pourquoi je fais ça
pour pas être amoureusement
maintenant je vous libère de l'accent
belge parce qu'on rentre dans des
questions compliquées ont cliqué donc je
ne veux pas que vous soyez à partir des
pertes sur 300 sionisme premières amours
premières amours martin il s'appelait
martin était plus âgées que vous non
même âge même âge quel âge et à quel âge
c'était
16 ans à 16 ans datant du 16 ans oui
j'étais très prude un trait aux
minguettes ça quel âge luis très jeune
mais sinon c'est grave aussi je connais
à suivre tu vas la pause et alors
premier baiser
exactement fernandez il pourrait la
faire à ma place c'était mission
maintien bons baisers premier baiser
c'était dans la cour de l'école en fait
je fantasmais sur un type et je crois
que je l'échoppé il était en short
c'était un cours de gym un et je sais
pas pourquoi je me suis avancé vers lui
et je l'embrassé sur la bouche
ça a été assez magique ouais voilà si tu
savais exactement comme avec le cnid en
bar mais finalement vous n'avez pas
beaucoup changé ça c'était sans la
langue ou avec la langue sans registre
des premiers baisers avec la langue
enfin c'était moins bien ah bon pourquoi
ça vous dégoûter la langue non mais je
m'en étais fait tout un monde enfin mais
en fait non non non avant c'était qui
hervé ben haddou il s'appelait au nom
les géniaux bon premier flirt poussé
flirt poussé
ben c'était c'était à 17 ans dans une
cabane dans la crau là la première fois
pour de vrai adacore bas ça c'était dans
le flou repoussée parce que j'entends je
pas commencé en belgique parce que
j'entends parfois repoussée on fait
beaucoup de choses mais on ne fait pas
la chose moi je me rappelle que de là
vraiment la bagarre est d'acord s'est
elle adore manger dans la manger quoi on
mangeait des miel pops
ça vous a marqué la madeleine c'est sa
première fois à trois et vous mets toi
c'est à troyes dans l'aube donc c'était
ya trop longtemps problème c'est que
c'était mon meilleur ami et sa fiancée
et ses parents selon laurent laurent
bonjour dirai pas plus bon d'accord
première fois à 4 ah ça non
premier chagrin d'amour t'as combien là
parce que j'ai du mal à suivre
premier chagrin d'amour la première fois
je devais avoir 20 ans j'étais amoureuse
d'un funambule qui m'a laissé tomber
comme une vieille chaussette on va
travailler pensionnat fils est tombé
première cuite première cuite c'était je
crois en pologne sous comme un polonais
ont dû toujours bêtement pologne sont
jamais mis trop de vodka ont tourné dans
les tatras
on était dans un hôtel qui ressemble à
un pelage à celui de shining voilà donc
on se console est temps qu'on pouvait
dans la vodka première cigarette au
cabanis jeunes aujourd'hui
j'aime pas quand dans vos émissions vous
poser la question sur le cabanis
d'accord hervé première cigarette au
cabanis ya pas très longtemps c'était à
la jamaïque web a marqué vous vous
bourrez en pologne
vous fumez vous fumez devers va jamais
que vous êtes quelque chose au bon
endroit bien première chose que vous
faites le matin en vous réveillant je
maranda très bonnes réponses dernière
chose que vous faites le soir avant de
vous coucher je me passe de la crème sur
les pieds sur les pieds non mais moi
et avant de vous endormir dernière chose
que vous faites c'est quoi avant de vous
coucher omettez de lachlan jolis pieds
prête à remettre bouchon de la trêve
avant de vous endormir
non je parle pas de trucs de sexe vous
pouvez faire une prière vous pouvez
faire votre examen de conscience
voilà vous avez l'air sincère quand on
vous dit que ça
ben ali
fabrice luchini
tu
interview première fois premier souvenir
quand je me suis noyée
vous êtes noyer et quand j'ai toujours
non à bandol je m'inscris dans une
piscine et ma mère m'a repêché de
justesse quand j'avais deux ans et en
fait c'est bizarre parce que j'ai le
souvenir des carreaux bleu quand je
coulais c'était agréable ne s'était pas
désagréable premier mensonge je sais pas
mentir premier péché je vois pas qu'est
ce qui est un péché d'accord première
baffe
jamais jamais et si une fois dans un
film
1 c'était dans la vraie vie non non ah
si une fois un type 1 type que je
connaissais pas non parce qu'en fait moi
je parle beaucoup et j'aime bien voyez
des petites vannes assez méchante et un
jour quelqu'un l'a très mal pris et je
me suis pris une baffe premier coup de
foudre
mon amour est ce qu'ils faisaient à zain
c'est moi qui fais des lasagnes un bon
d'accord premier baiser sur la bouche
sans la langue je suis pas non ça n'est
pas non en fait c'est fait je m'en
excuse en voilà ouais ouais annoncée
très tard et est traitée avec un
décalage trop tard non je ne dirais pas
c'est la honte
genre 12 13 ans non 16
ouais première fois toute nue avec un
garçon boucher pareil c'était le jour où
il fallait être là quoi
la première fois à troyes jamais jamais
encore pas même pas encore n'ont jamais
ça vous plaît pas vous intéresse pas ça
m'intéresse pas du tout du tout du tout
du tout première fois quatre donc ces
imbéciles doublement des 64
premier chagrin d'amour 17
mais en fait non non parce que non j'ai
pas non en fait c'est bête mais je
regrette d'avoir eu un chagrin d'amour
pour lui
ouais il méritait pas ça grimpe aulas la
première scène de ménage avec sus des
lasagnes je crois jamais jamais encore
si wesh
j'ai mûri caractère pas bon ouais je
m'énerve je claque la porte et où je
sais dure pas longtemps ça dure pas
longtemps
non j'y arrive pas vous avez passé une
chute et n'en resterai avec chirac pas
ouais c'est ça vous fait la tête ça vous
fait du mal donc vous retourne à qui
revient le premier c'est vous c'est lui
moi là faites attention pas être soumise
comme ça ils résistent pas pardon il
résiste pas mon cas je comprends un peu
rude sa première cuite datant encore en
fait je suis spécial coup je ne bois pas
d'alcool mais ce qui me saoule c'est une
coca
cocasse à soulever de al qods rien
n'annonce un non mais c'est vrai ah bon
oui je dis que l'économie ait pas
d'alcool
rothé c'était ma fille lola déjà culte
chiite
suit les lasagnes premier pétard en fait
je suis me tâte plus tard mais je fume
passivement parce que je suis fan de
concert de reggae donc si votre façon de
vous dépenser ce qui concerne la
jeunesse tient ça suffit première
cigarette autorisé cette maman
c'est dans ouais et votre mère vous
laisser fumer reste et on m'a fait
essayer j'ai trouvé ça tellement
dégueulasse que je n'ai plus jamais
chemin et jeunes filles pas balbo ch et
un film c'est quoi ces matériaux
prochaine fois non non prochain image en
effet un autre après qui s'appelle sexe
très opposées d'eric assous
non non voyons non mais j'ai pas un rôle
très important dans le prochain film
c'est à voir je ne sais pas encore votre
merdier du journal pour garder petites
annonces non j'ai un agent maintenant
quand même compliqué quand même
comme cette très jeune on va faire une
interview première fois vous savez on
embauche parking
[Musique]
le premier mensonge ou tôt quoi par
exemple je sais pas et comme la premère
d'élèves de la maternelle je sais pas le
trait menteuse faut s'en méfier
je serai hélène je viens d'aller
chercher tout de suite il ya eu la
remise votre premier choc ya pas très
longtemps grave hein oui oui on va trop
en parler alors votre première baffe
c'était avec mon papa tu t'es petit il
voulait dormir il était fatigué c'est un
dimanche après midi
moi j'étais très nerveuse je trouverais
dans tous les sens j'étais avec mon
petit magnétophone et je faisais
peut-être un petit peu de bruit
c'était peut-être la goutte qui a fait
déborder le vase en supprime sa ré et
pourtant vous ne voulez pas vous
habitait toujours chez lui
oui votre première idéale
c'est un stage là ils ont besoin de se
sentir aimé désiré un merci ma petite
votre premier baiser sans la langue la
maternelle ah ouais mais j'avais pas de
chance parce que j'étais amoureuse d'un
garçon qui me trouvais pas joli non plus
du coup à son copain ou partie des
copains d'accord c'était une tournante
donc ça c'était sans la langue à votre
premier baiser avec la lande
13 ans olol alors ça s'est fait laminer
mais le lendemain matin dix ans est
définie ah ouais c'est dégueulasse
d'accord qu'elle briseuse de coeur
la première fois tout seul non c'est une
question alors j'vais vous dire la
vérité sur cette question je n'avais pas
pensé que j'ai reçue non mais c'est vrai
j'ai reçu un email d'un mec qui me dit
quand tu fais l'interview première fois
tu te demandes toujours la première fois
de la première fois à 3 pourquoi tu
demande pas la première fois tout seul
vous en souvenez pas jamais tout seul
non ah bon la première fois deux ils
étaient jeunes en fait foi j'aime
globalement abord très de la patience
maman ou là c'est que j'ai deux filles
là ça m'inquiète parce que j'entends ce
soir maintenant on innove elle vous
couchez première fois à troyes ah bon ça
vous intéresse pas c'est pas trio du
tout du tout à 4 non plus donc j'arrête
là c'est pas les chiffres pairs
c'est calé au site encore premier
chagrin d'amour à 15 1 à 15 ans déjà
vous avez tout fait ou à l'âge de 15 ans
il était finie c'était la première fois
que je tombais amoureuse première fois
que je me donnais à quelqu'un vous avez
souffert d'un mois j'étais folle
amoureuse lui même et pas du tout
pourrait bien que c'était juste pour
tirer son coup comme on peut dire
vulgairement donc j'en étais malade
après c'est là que j'ai commencé à boire
première cuite secor première cuite et
mais j'ai jamais une première qui sait
ce soir alors jamais vous n'êtes jamais
avec encore un verre de verte à puce
c'est bien pour les pétards non 16 ans
16 ans pardon c'est cette saison oui
j'aime ça parce que votre mère regard
mais on annonce est vrai 16v bourges
quelque chose que j'aime pas comment vos
émissions vous poser la question sur le
cabanis d'accord hervé première
cigarette 14 ans ouais premier valium
pas encore bravo vous félicite vous
allez avoir droit ça ne vous étonnera
pas à une interview première fois dit
bush
[Applaudissements]
mon fils ma fille n'a pas bougé alors
attention attention premier souvenir
je sais quand je sautais sur le lit de
ma cousine et je suis tombé je me suis
déchiré le dos sur une étagère de
briques elles venant d'irak au gymnase
chat pebbles alors ouais la cause et n'a
eu la chance et se fait mal
oui premier choc j'imagine que c'est
celui-là premier choc
ben non j'ai déjà pris un choc
électrique en voulant jouer à la voiture
que j'avais des clones dans ce que
j'avais des clés j'allais rentrer dans
la prise de courant c'est qu'on devait
croiser québécoise à 4 ans et je le fais
aussi hommage au moins 210 à
l'épanouissement au premier mensonge off
ça doit être une fois que j'ai dit à ma
mère c'est pas moi ouais c'est sûr
vincent premier péché mon père
d'ailleurs mon premier péché oui le
mensonge
ah oui vincent quelconque je sais pas
lequel première baffe
j'en ai jamais eu jamais vous essayez
c'est peut-être même essayé ma fille tu
es mort en des toits oui ben ari faire
des cures et tué le tueur est rentré
oui mon fils
il est complètement tombé première idole
céline dion on est on répond mais moi
j'aime beaucoup même s'il est bon c'est
vrai oui oui les derniers seront les
premiers jeux ne touchait plus belle
chance à ilhem céline dion elvis presley
n'est pas mort belle robe âgées jamais
pour thomas rabe l'eurovision ce gâteau
que je m eu droit à leur vision je vais
mettre une robe donc si elle est belle
ce sera la première premier coup de
foudre
premier coup de foudre
je sais pas je veux être à peu près
présent 15 1 15 ans est alors alors bas
ça a été mon premier mon premier copain
sérieux et alors quoi alors après alors
que je alors après j'ai eu à notre coup
de foudre
je sors un livre chez latex germa qu'on
en parle comme ça votre promo comme
celle et ses traits de votre site est
pas trompé jeu rapide de requins savez
très bien marché premier baiser sur la
bouche
14 15 1 première fois avec la langue
ah ben je pensais que c'est cool je vais
l'avouer à la d'accord au québec c'est
comme si on remet la langue tout de
suite des fois oui des fois non première
fois à 2 j'ai pas demandé première fois
tout seul parce que bon je peux pas avec
le père qui est là et tout temps va
changer parce que n'avoir pas que j'ai
couché avec un mec sans le savoir je
devais avoir la fin de mes 15 ans
presque 16 dhabi choc mais de tout ça te
fait dire première fois à 300 pages
qu'on a fait ça mais jamais encore
arrivé non c'est pour ça que vous non sa
première fois à 4 c je vous le demande
premier chagrin d'amour premier chagrin
d'amour il ya
neuf mois après c'est le vélo ouais donc
voilà donc c'était ouais c'était c'était
mon ancien copain tête à la première
fois par nonu ah bah oui on est restés
des très bons copains
c'est très sympa mais c'est pas qu'on
était des très bons copains le premier
mois après la rupture mais maintenant
oui alors appuyé première cuite c'était
juste après alors non c'était avant
première cuite c'est à chez mes parents
je devais avoir 15 ans à 15 ans et elle
a 15 ans il s'est passé des trucs
vraiment demain je baise premier pétard
premier pétard jamais avant
[Applaudissements]
quant à sam il en existe voyelles et
portant des noms à l'alluré fière de lui
non un jour d'août soyons clairs ouais
je vois pas en quoi la religion
catholique pourrait nous interdire de
fumer des pétards attendait les noms du
moment s'il n'y a pas de dépendance
oui d'accord mais le spectacle pas dès
maintenant pour des fins thérapeutiques
on sait que ça aide beaucoup c'est ça
peut avoir du bon il ya des gens quand
le concert et qui ont fait fumer des
pétards
ouais ben ali étant c'est pas la peine
d'avoir le cancer je le dis bon première
cigarette or là c'est beaucoup plus
grand mais non plus ça c'est bien ça je
vous félicite
ouais premier valium sait jamais c'est
bien bravo bravo bravo c'est le football
malien
on ne couche pas pendant les ting
[Applaudissements]
on ne bouge pas pendant les jean galle
bien ça c'est fait
interview première fois premier souvenir
ma première fois à tout de suite bah oui
c'est un grand truc dont on parle de
sexe j'ai peur mais ça aurait pu être
sympa moi se trouve et avant 13 ans vous
avez commencé tard en plus 15 ans et
demi s'est bien rattrapé redevenir
premier choc de votre vie c'est pas
obligatoire du sexe on ya pas longtemps
c'était avec un membre de ma famille
je voulais nous est survenu et voilà
quand je vais me gêner
premier mensonge il n'a pas duré
longtemps c'était une tromperie
les trompes et vague oui non mais ça
durait deux jours je le jure on est
déçus il a fait avant moi
c'est scandaleux la destruction du
premier péché la gourmandises sucrées
première main mon papa ouais premier
coup de foudre
greg grèce aux grecs quand même premier
baiser sans la langue sans la langue
c'était tard ah bon j'ai commencé avec
la langue
j'ai déjà mon mac comédie ce magot t
attendais je souhaitais en quatrième
xavier gachet qui n ont pas quel âge
sa maison est alors maintenant ils
arrivent et avec la danse avec la langue
avec la langue si tu n'es pas un an plus
tard pour la première fois alors danse
avec greg
oui à l'âge de 16 ans oui je dis oui
comme ça parce qu'un essai avec
quelqu'un d'autre mais c'était un très
mauvais souvenir
ah bon c'est pas bien passé ma première
vraie foi voilà des premières fois avec
une fille c'était pour une femme c'était
pour l'anniversaire de greg je comprends
pas on peut heureusement plus souvent
paré paré un nom exactement c'est une
fille dont j'avais envie et finalement
ça c'est pas prévu on était dans une
soirée tout ça et on est rentrés tous
les trois voilà ça n'a pas duré gré il
ya un bravo et bilal félicitations ces
situations très bonne idée dieu vous
vous rendrez jamais avec un copain
vaincus pour avoir des copains oui il
pourrait avoir envie de rentrer avec un
copain greg aussi frais que ce soit moi
qui en ai envie ah bon c'est vous qui
décidez oui mais je pense que c'est
normal dans un couple que ce soit la fin
la femme a plus besoin de choses pour le
sexe comme un homme c'est assez facile
elle est pas mal c'est bien enfin
souvent une fille a plus besoin d'eux
des choses pour la première fois à
troyes vous venez de le dire première
fois 4 enfin tout dire c'était y'a pas
longtemps et a5 jamais ah bon vous êtes
tout à apprendre encore premières scènes
de ménage quand même j'espère que c'est
assez a longtemps à eric beaucoup depuis
ouais on discute beaucoup un nom aime
bien vous aimez bien dans la
réconciliation même si bien sûr les
premiers amours c'est qui votre vrai
premier amour pareil non bah oui
gx est là
c'est fred coppula
avec
alors loup demain c'est la première fois
que tu montes parle de vous donc on va
vous faire une interview première fois
[Musique]
le premier souvenir mon premier souvenir
lenny kravitz j'ai rencontré à 16 ans et
dans un bar vous avez parlé
ah ouais ouais je vais parler j'ai une
grande photo labo portrait tous étaient
tout fiers
premier mensonge strato un way très très
tôt très tôt
je devais avoir 6 ans jeux 1,6 en traite
première baffe très tôt aussi voulait
juste après mensongère c'est quoi ce que
j'ai fait mais je pense même ma grande
soeur m'avait surpris entre et faire des
bisous à un garçon gagne est ravi non
non non pas encore non non mais voilà et
puis ça se faisait pas dans la famille
version première fois que vous avez fait
pleurer votre mère quand je suis parti
de chez moi que l'âge 16 ans première
injustice dont vous ayez été victime je
dirais
jetez moi j'irai le décès de mon frère
mais je sais pour moi c'est une
injustice mais qui est pas toi voilà
premier jour à l'école
très bien jamais bien l'école huawei se
contenterait premières vacances la
tanger avec mes parents oui combien
belle robe
les jours du mariage de ma soeur qui
aideront à une très jolie robe pour les
coups de foudre à 20 ans avec un
quelqu'un d'autre est beaucoup plus
justement première déclaration d'amour
chez maman l'entarteur godin pouvait
baiser sur la bouche
je les fais très rarement mon premier
je vais avoir 15 ans un truc comme ça
oui je suivais les copines parce que
tout le monde avait fait rose en moi
j'avais encore rien vu c'était avec la
langue
non c'était sans la langue et avec la
lange et avec la langue
ça a été bien plus tard web évident
précoce première fois avec un garçon
première fois avec un garçon à 21 ans 2e
fois moi ça continue première fois à
troyes jamais à quatre premières
ruptures première rupture première
grande rupture 20
ap ap ap j'avais 23 ans resté un mois et
demi avec ah oui c'est dur c'était dur
oui c'était dur mais j'ai souffert
personnellement j'ai souffert celle d un
franchement maintenant c'est parce que
j'ai vraiment souffert
j'ai eu un moment de spleen terrible
c'était écrit tu m'a pas répondu
je téléphonais terre et station
répondeur c'est vrai et ça m'a pas plu
du tout et après quand j'ai su que tu
avais un petit enfant j'ai vraiment eu
mal mais maintenant quel effet ça te
fait de me revoir
vas y écoute j'aimerais bien qu'on sera
parle un peu plus tard et puis quand on
met les choses au tu veux pas
recommencer à zéro
très bien tout ça c'est pas ça se
discute
j'ai une situation très confortable mais
je passe dans l'émission d'ardisson si
maintenant on a tu fais comme tu veux
c'est quand tu voudras c'est quand même
marrant vous retrouvez ici tous les
autres est bizarre c'est fou ça c'est la
vie c'est le mektoub statut c'est
incroyable certains en vrais bisons
c'est insensé et elle n'a pas changé un
peu vieilli premier pétard premier
pétard il n'ya pas longtemps mais
j'adore ça
voilà le nasa mal dans le film d'andré
téchiné nous appelle
non
marc près de chez vous attention on ne
bougera rien
c'est bien tous les cas il ya un truc je
vais bien répéter c'est corrigé par un
logiciel saas et bien déjà
donc j'ai dû recommencer parce que
souvent pour commencer alors là il ya
quelques questions dont j'ai les
réponses vous n'avez pas intérêt à me
raconter des conneries
par exemple premier baiser
l'âge est le nom du garçon oui 13 ans
oui en voyant le sens des mots assez
durs à l'est pas menteuse
la première fois que vous avez fait
l'amour vous aviez quel âge et lui que
l'âge 16 ans lui 34 bravo le jeu quel
âge aviez quand je vois déjà répondre à
ces questions mais vous êtes allés avec
votre maman chez le gynécologue pour
qu'il vous donne la pilule
quel âge vous aviez quel âge vous aviez
même avec la première fois l'amour en
même temps très organisé logique
attention j'ai toutes les réponses la
première fois à troyes
à 4 non plus à 5 non plus non mais
attendez des gens qui font ce n'est pas
parce que vous êtes à ma droite et le
centre ou arrière via connais les
chiffres impairs sait jamais première
fois avec une fille ça dépend donc rien
on va vous avez fait l'amour avec une
fille jamais encore découvrir bon ça je
sais pas je oui pourquoi pas salir je
deviens une expérience avec une fille
vous suis pas prononcé
glv premier chagrin d'amour
j'ai pas vraiment eu de chagrin d'amour
non j'étais un sincère mais évite au
nombre à bord non première cui jian
dinars à la première dont je me
souvienne vraiment c'est le soir du bas
que j'avais 17 ans ouais pourquoi parce
que vous l'aviez raté vous avez vu je
l'avais raté j'étais la seule je
comprends premier pétard 19 ans car il
est très tardif jack sur le banc et mais
entre-temps dernières volontés si vous
deviez mourir là maintenant tout de
suite ses pas et vous votre dernière
volonté je deviens mourir lannoy ça
serai je veux pas je ne veux pas
interview comme c'est la première fois
qu'on se voit première fois on ne bouge
pas pendant le thing en bouche même
pendant les gardes
[Musique]
bien premier souvenir estelle souvenir
c'est très beau et je sais pas la
première fois que j'arrive à paris
première baffe sur les fesses dans le
dernier film j'ai pas dix ans à l'âge de
10 ans je me rappelle ces deux ans vous
aviez fait quoi vous souvenez vous avez
failli faire un incendie les gens
attention alors attention pour les
questions suivantes j'ai des réponses et
pas intérêt à me raconter des conneries
premier baiser qu'elle est d'abord sur
la bouche h
quel âge à part ça très bien avec qui le
prénom il s'appelle 10 2vic nom cyrill
oui exact
je sais
oui c'est comme ça quelque chose
première fois l'amour c'est génial oui
très bien et le mec avec l âge ah ils
étaient plus vieux que moi il avait 24
oui je sais ça braille et 24 ans et
c'était dans une voiture la marque de la
voiture s'il vous plaît fier que n'est
pas pour ça que vous écoutiez mozart
non la marge de la belle-soeur première
fois avec une fille
j'avais 17 ans et demi première fois à
troyes je me rappelle putelat jeu mais
c'était après 17 ans j'avais déjà vers
18 ans quand tu étais bien coincé quand
même
ça
toulouse avec une première fois quand
même c'est beau les routes étaient
timides première fois à beaucoup pour la
rai 18 19 ans d'accord là aussi j'ai la
réponse attention première ce dos c'est
bravo connais tous à hyères première
saudeau et fellation en même temps j'ai
la réponse aussi ils étaient deux dans
projet x déjà on avait femmes sur canal
rangez les messieurs nascar
ici on littéraire
par amour tu serais prêt prête à quoi
les sciences est la question que s'il de
coûts est-ce que par amour ou seriez
prête à embrasser cent fois les
chaussettes sales de votre fiancée faire
une interview première fois vous êtes
prêt en bouche pendant les finales
qu'est ce que c'est que ça j'ai oublié
qu'il avait bougé la fin qu'il fallait
je sais pas je sais plus il n'a fait que
bouger je regardais les autres soeurs
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a bougé ou pas
qu'est ce que tu en penses
comme dit l'interview voilà comme d'une
interview alors premier souvenir comment
mêmes parents ma mère m'a enfermé dans
un placard elle m'a oublié viennent mais
ne s'en souvient pas première prise
juste avant j'imagine des gens comme et
une autre à l'âge de trois ans 6,35
terrible avant j'avais tiré l'alarmé il
y avait une arme à la maison ça c est l
art du chauffeur de votre alarme du
chauffeur devant père j'ai pris un petit
6 35 chargé et je suis arrivé il y avait
des invités et j'ai fait aux les mains
et tout le monde a levé les mains
première aventure avec un garçon sage
vous aventure aventure touche pipi quoi
oui il ya peu il ya eu une période où
j'étais tout le temps à mettre tout nu
avec des pillards sans je sais pas si
vous avez fait ça enfin bien sûr mais
moi aussi j'ai fait ça et là et donc
vers le mexique
huit ans oui oui c'était terrain et
c'était bah oui c'était ce qui m'étonne
c'est que ça se passait très très
rapidement grèce est très très vatican
quoi premier baiser
on va en provence
mais j'étais un peu petit et gtc est
monté sur un tronc d'arbre
mais ça avait pris des heures après six
heures pour moi c'est la glace et ça
fait très vieux après pour ça recommence
isr surtout les jeunes gens très vieux
jeu moyen ça va beaucoup plus vite
première expérience sexuelle en
l'attention j'ai aussi la réponse je
vois tout à fait où c'était avec qui 16
ans ouais c'est ça chez un copain
pendant l'été jean marie elle s'appelait
comment ironique
bravo à lui c'est là qu'il a ressorti
son 6,35 qui étaient chargés couvert par
tous
c'est parce que c'est par j'ai jamais vu
ça ouais mais bon alors une partie
carrée oui bon peuple perd 2,18 encore
19 ans et vous me direz vous avez des
partis car est aussi oui je gêne pas
pour couvrir abacha j'ai les parties
cargo de quoi et les coups ils sont
chassés
comme un accord très bon disque ça va la
forme vous fait vous êtes en forme
physiquement musicalement ça se passe
bien ouais c'est mon avis pas loin
didier
[Applaudissements]
pour la gauche pas
premier souvenir je devais avoir un an
et demi ou deux ans et mon papa
m'emmenait dans un espèce de casting je
crois et je vais être sur scène et
bouger avec la chanson où la chanteuse
elle est amoureuse nom ou la menteuse
elle est amoureuse par un et je me
sentais très très mal et je me suis mise
à pleurer et
mon père m'a pris dans ses bras et on
m'a posé sur une table où il y avait
plein de chaussures et le mec qui
faisait le casting nous a demandé d'en
choisir une
et mon père a pris juste celle que je
voulais pas j'espérais vraiment qu'il
n'avait pas prendre celle d'ouvrir les
vannes d'un truc énorme notre jeu c'est
terrible et pour en parler pendant des
heures c'est vraiment ça fait qu'il ait
remarqué tout un beau fusil le casting
très très jeunes enfants sur les
musiques de dorothée en plus mais voilà
ça donne ça traumatise premier choc
le père noël n'existe pas ça c'était
terrible j'ai pleuré ça m'a traumatisée
que lashkar saison 6 en six ans un
premier péché l'envi de luxure peut-être
à 4 ans avec mathieu la coach
4 4 4 première baffe alors celle dont je
me souvienne mais c'était sans doute pas
la première je vais avoir 8 ans et et je
courais pour pas que ma maman me foute
une baffe et helm a loupé elle m'a tapé
dans le ventre et ça m'a fait très mal
elle a perdu l'enfant pour les coups de
foudre à se mettre maintenant après
premier baiser sur la bouche dans une
fête en belgique jerry 12 ans avec la
langue ou 100 m
alors en fait ça ces bases et
bizarrement on voulait la vraie histoire
parce qu'il ya une série sans la langue
est en fait j'ai traversé la rue il y en
avait un autre qui était julien ennemis
celtes avec la langue adacore le même
jour sur la vie avec l'habitat alors
qu'on est en droit première fois 14 ans
avec alex lee lors d'orgies ces jeunes
ben ça c'est tout est de la faute de
mathieu sans doute oui lancé un appel
pour alex mon sens tout par jacques et
mathieu en fait que le droit de revenir
quoi maintenant mais c'est l'espace de
si ça se trouve
inconsciemment je ne sais que chercher
l'image de mathieu que je ne retrouverai
jamais existé mais que je le revois
paquet première fois à troyes j'aimais
ballon trop de problèmes à 2 pourra être
à 3 pour l'instant première fois quatre
soit la peine que je vous demande donc
premier chagrin d'amour
vrai chagrin d'amour c'était ya pas très
longtemps il ya enfin ça a duré trois
ans en fait aussi longtemps que
l'histoire et c'était avec mon petit ami
américain
c'était comment faisait quoi actares
première tentative de suicide mathieu 15
en personne pourquoi je sais plus
dernière chose que vous feriez si vous
deviez mourir là maintenant tout de
suite
overdose de drogues dures
[Musique]
tu as touché chez vous j'ai bougé mais
on rallume zabou on va faire une
interview première fois en à gauche
pendant l'été
[Musique]
moi je peux pas je ris je voudrais vous
vous êtes comme des statues j'arrive pas
à van avant qu'il le dise faut avoir
chopé une position qui est confortable
comme ça sans lessive bio sans
expression zabou premier mensonge est
vachement souviens pas j'ai la mémoire
première fois où vous avez fait pleurer
votre mère à jeu une fois elle était
venue me coucher et puis je voulais pas
qu'elle s'en aille
je ne voulais pas qu'elle parte je
voulais qu'elle chante encore une
chanson est encore une chanson est
encore une chanson je m'étais pendu
littéralement à son cou accrochée et je
lui avais fait mal au cou et il avait pu
aurait alors là ça a été terrible pour
première première belle robe première
belle robe alors pour moi mais bon pour
moi petite firme ça a été la panoplie
d'isabelle en arômes de mama pleinement
en même temps premiers flirts ckoi flirt
la roulage de pelle pelotage de leader
tout je suis blanche poids
avec avec la langue
je fais mon premier flirt alors si vous
dites que c'est ça je l'épousé c'est lui
oui mais entre temps vous êtes un peu en
trente ans et qui est étonnant c'est
perdu de vue sa mère d'une dizaine
d'années et puis on s'est retrouvés
c'est beau mais c'est très beau premier
chagrin d'amour
oui je me souviens on se devait partir
en vacances avec lui il m'a dit
oh non en mettant et me dire au nom du
parti en vacances juste et au téléphone
je sais comment mais pourquoi et j'ai
dit mais la question qu'il faut
absolument pas posée je fais mieux que
tu m'aimes plus et m'a dit non m'a fait
ben non j'ai été abominable première
fois première fois c'était un peu comme
savez quand vous j'avais tellement les
chocottes que c'était un peu comme quand
vous avalez un médicament pas terrible
évident d'oublier un grand verre d'eau
bah c'est bien expliqué qu'elle ne
s'était pas comme des poèmes que
j'écrivais à 13 ans elle est d'accord
après mêlée première fois c'était une
première expérience homosexuelle
demain demain dakar première fois à 3
après demain donc je vous demande pas à
4 en trois jours
sage quand même hein je sais pas si
c'est de la sagem première cuite d'avoir
15 ans j'avais bu un grand verre jetpack
en tous genres pastis ou un truc comme
ça ou deux il est malade comme un chien
et je me souviens qu'ils avaient comme
musique de fond
sister jane de comment ça s'appelait de
deux de taï phong qui était le groupe
jane et moi j'ai comme un chien c'était
épouvantable premier pétard à la
campagne un truc avait poussé dans le
jardin d'un mec et je trouvais que
c'était mauvais comme
et ils étaient tous très bizarre après
et moi je me suis dit faut que ce soit
comme le nom qu'ils jouaient tous de la
batterie je ne suis pas pourquoi il n'y
avait pas de battre bijoux et où il
était chauve là aussi ai-je fait de la
batterie et je me suis dit il faut
sûrement jouer de la batterie pour
comprendre premier incident dans une
semaine comme et valium ah non j'en ai
pas prévalu au lexomil
oui j'en ai pris des fois ça m'est
arrivé une ou deux fois un quart de ce
petit truc qui est pas très bon
justement pour la mémoire c'est
tellement beau jour qui prennent ça
comme ça on n'a pas ça va me calmer
alors c'est pas bon du tout du tout pour
la mémoire c'est vraiment moche donc
pour faire vraiment tout doucement
zabou premier film comme réalisatrice
sagement son bien oui c'est quoi se
souvenir des belles choses très bien
vous le savez le macho mais isabelle
carré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
premier souvenir premier sonia je pense
que ça serait vraiment ma première scène
en fait tout simplement parce que ça a
été beaucoup de stress pour moi et je
m'en rappelle encore donc c'est vraiment
le souvenir qui me reviendrait en
réfléchissant premier objet fétiche
ben en fait c'est un grigri que j'ai
toujours et que j'ai trouvé il ya à peu
près trois ans avec l'homme avec qui je
suis aujourd'hui on la trouvait au bord
de la route et on a senti vu ce que
c'était ce que c'était une matière un
petit peu c'est quoi c'est quoi un petit
peu comme la sorcellerie souffre parce
que c'est ce que j'ai peur que ça marche
plus après mes deux matières envoyées
comme les dents des trucs comme ça mais
d'animal c'est pas un truc d'êtres
humains qu'on a trouvé mais c'est une
matière vivante en fait qu'on a trait au
bord de la route et c'était pas celle du
tout c'est pour ça que l'on ramassé 1 je
tiens à préciser ces patients latex non
non je ne dirais pas ce que c'est parce
que je suis très superstitieuse mais
voilà c'est ça c'est un grigri en fait
que je mets dans une petite boîte
donc c'est plus comme ça et là non par
contre je perds tout donc tous mes trucs
porte bonheur tous mes clichés que
j'élève sur la ba je me mets en relation
avec et voilà premier péché franchement
je suis tellement de sage mois
je n'aime pas l'alcool on va dire ces
cigarettes simplement quand j'avais 14
ans parce que le reste tout ce qui est
c'est que je veux dire c'est pas
dépêcher pour moi on aime quelqu'un
qu'on est bien avec lui c'est pas un
pêcheur je parlerai pas de ça tout seul
ça a pêché non conflit on va sur que non
j'étais rekom olivier chez les curés
donc pour nous tous tes péchés n'est-ce
pas tout ce qui apporte du bonheur et
pêcher voilà c'est ça
les débuts
oui paix chez vous j'ai cambrioler une
maison quand j'avais 8 ans 1
une première belle robe première belle
robe vraiment la première très très
belle c'était dans le métier quand j'ai
fait une cérémonie
c'était une remise de prix en fait
c'était comme l'énergie music awards
mais notre chaîne banque a déjà pas quoi
mais j'avais vraiment une bonne droite
vers le monde des autres chaînes je
préfère pas quand même à bord le
show-business maintenant les discussions
des chaînes concurrentes chichi savourer
ça ici m6 awards
mais voilà premier baiser premier baiser
j'avais 12 ans et je peux dire son nom
c'était yoann et ça s'est très bien
passé j'étais vraiment excité je me
rappelle que quand on a commencé à
s'embrasser en était debout et à la fin
j'ai ouvert les yeux et j'étais en fait
à six ans les marges escaliers parce
qu'on était à l'arrêt bus et donc je
sais pas comment je me suis retrouvé à
six comme ça mais il a laissé passer un
tourbillon et qui m'a fait tomber quoi
c'est assez impressionnant avec la
langue au 100m en la voyant je sais pas
cela l'ambiance est à 7 ans mettez pas
la langue tout de suite à olivier on ne
met pas la langue
premier flirt poussé premier faire
pousser je devais avoir dix sept ans et
c'était en fait dans une ruelle juste en
face de chez moi donc je me rappelle que
je devais rentrer et ma mère était au
balcon et elle disait je l'entendais
dire à mon père mais qu'est ce qui est
fait est dors et déjà être là et du coup
moi ça m'a excité forcément de savoir
mes parents me chercher et on s'est mis
dans que contre la rue fin contre le mur
et là c'est vrai que ça a été la
première fois que c'était un peu plus et
mais justement on n'est pas passé à
l'acte c'est première fois alors très
très poussées voilà n'est pas plus ou
moins première fois avec un garçon 18
ans donc c'est qu'un an après la
première fois poussé et c'est toujours
le même avec son fidèle tout ceci c'est
incroyable les premières fois avec une
fille
jamais un bon jeu que 21 ans le meilleur
reste à venir je plaisante
trois jeunes et non plus j'aime c'est
beaucoup de choses à découvrir
jean faure à vous raconter ma vie et
fait des découvertes
premier chagrin d'amour
j'en ai pas mal hein ouais peut-être il
a commencé vers mes 13 ans après que
j'ai eu mon premier garçon a tout l'air
tentative de suicide jamais jamais c'est
pas très grave alors recherche en
allemand non ça va je m'en remets
toujours premiers valium témesta lexomil
je n'ai pas de drogue alors non jamais
jamais pas même pas de juin rien la
drogue douce on va dire oui j'oubliais
première infidélité
oui c'est vrai qu'avant ben justement
c'était à me 17 ans il m'est arrivé
carrément de sortir avec 3 mais quand
même tour mais je les sentais que
c'était pas dit retro satana vous ne
savez pas heureusement donc ça va je
dirais ça le week-end
il y avait moi
pour nous aussi
mélanie comme si la bonne entente fois
on va vers une première fois dans la
bouche
votre premier souvenir j'étais tout tout
tout tout bébé et les gens croient pas
quand je raconte ça mais j'étais bébé
parce que je pouvais même pas marcher ni
avancer et ma mère était au dessus de
moi j'étais allongée et elle est partie
je sais pas chercher une couche chercher
un truc et j'ai eu un énorme sentiment
d'abandon de voir partir ma maman elle
pas pouvoir la suivre
je me souviens suivant jamais ouais
ouais bah voilà non mais c'est vrai je
suis la personne la croix là dessus des
2 puis vous raccrocher aux makes à cause
de ça voilà exactement cette fin
psychologue fait bien votre billet choc
si si j'ai failli me faire renverser par
une voiture
quand j'étais petit dans un camping
votre première baffe
je me suis dit c'est la première et la
seule c'est mon père qui
ma chercher une bonne partie de la
soirée je devais avoir 12 13 ans sinon
encore en camping on fait beaucoup de
campings et c'est très bien et j'étais
dans une soirée j'ai jamais quitté le
camping mais lui il a fait tous les bars
du coin il a eu super peur et est rentré
il m'a donné une baffe et je me suis
fait pipi dessus tellement j'ai eu peur
j'adore c'est trop sexuel ça je te fais
pipi dessus
j'avais 12 ans a même 12 ans mon four
première idole
la première idole michel bouquet
c'est fou ça ouais j'ai toujours adoré
michel bouquet et vous adorez toujours
way toujours gel google reader sur la
niche bouquet premier petit premier
petit ami mon premier petit ami
quoi pas sérieux ou sérieux un retourné
petite table il première série passe
rien je veux dire les doigts pas les
doigts d'or les doigts c'est un moyen
sûr et un dégueulasse et
il m'a mis en file et c'est non non je
suis resté un an avec lui et
j'ai du mal à marcher à tomber dans
tirez vous et voilà ça a été un bon
signe c'était celui qui vous a fait
votre premier baiser sur la bouche non
alors premier baiser sur la bouche
fruits baiser sur la bouche étaient
encore en camping c'est au cap d'agde
quoi la bbc alors donc j'étais un
hollandais dont je me souvenais un
colorant de galles le cadet du gard
alors essayez voilà je me souviens qu'il
était vachement plus grand que moi et
que les pointes pour l'embrasser quoi il
y avait la langue ou pas il y avait la
langue tout de suite allant au bout de
la première fois ouais ouais j'ai super
peur
la première fois avec un chien alors ça
va bien on parle et envoie ça ne va pas
du tout ah bon non non non non parce que
c'est un labrador je suis assez fier et
très très beau c'est la vie de maisons
wacrenier chaleur d'amour une premier
chagrin d'amour géré mis du temps à m'en
remettre
le labrador est parti baas affirment
qu'ils savaient pas écrire
ouais j'ai vu
ouais c'était un peu douloureux je suis
parti vivre à l'étranger pour laisser
vous êtes exilé ou à londres pendant
combien de temps
9 - 9 mois tentative de suicide
non non quand même pas non plus c'était
pas c'est la séparation venait de moi
donc non pas du tout c'est un être ce
que j'aimerais qu'il met la gomme
sérieusement c'est pourquoi vous l'avez
quittée je crois qu'on était parti sur
des mauvaises bases on était super jeune
quand on s'est rencontré et quand on en
reparle maintenant ce que maintenant on
est amis on rigole de l'attitude qu'on
avait même pas quoi et aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui vous êtes combler tout va
bien tu savais qu'elle est elle venue à
voici
l'ancien dahomey
on se met pas comment ce que l'état on
va faire une interview première fois
[Applaudissements]
alors attention ça commence simplement
premier choc premier choc
ah oui ça c'est quand comme mon papa
était parti de chez nous vous aviez 12
ans 6 12 ans que vous apprenez que vos
parents avaient divorcé au fait parce
que ma maman elle comptait la mare hier
quand elle a épousé mon père elle était
encore très jeune et puis elle savait
pas vraiment si elle était amoureuse ou
palm époque elle est tombée enceinte et
puis c'était obligé qu'est-ce qu'elle se
marie et et quand j'avais 3 ans elle a
trouvé un autre en main c'est à tomber
amoureuse il ya ya ya ya soixantaine
dentition un truc je pense à cette femme
qui qui d'un coup tombe sur un autre
homme qui lui convient mieux et c'est la
vie qui arrivent de plus en plus sur
deux se termine en divorce
c'est terrible c'est ça c'est terrible
parce que ça fait très mal aux enfants
lance mario bien alors donc
effectivement premier péché péché qu'est
ce que ça fait chier à ses quelque chose
de mal qu'on a fait ou à la wii c'est
quand j'ai par là là c'est quand je suis
parti partie de la maison pendant trois
jours et ma mère savait pas où j'étais
en fait je suis parti avec les amis à
moi on était dans son défi c'était
un garçon et deux filles et on est parti
on savait même pas où dans une maison
faite le garçon il nous a dit j'ai les
clès et une maison à la campagne c'est
très sympa et où on est allé on est
parti de la maison et à la fin on s'est
rendu compte qu'il n'avait pas de créer
en fait on est rentré dedans un peu en
force et c'est contre la loi
mais c'est en république tchèque s'était
pas ici premier coup de foudre j'ai eu
14 ans je suis tombée amoureuse vraiment
d'un photographe
non pas du tout terreur et vous les
filles vont toutefois devoir et non moi
n'ont jamais je pense que
pascal parts échec des photographes le
soir et nuit donc très tôt aux
seychelles stéréotypes et non sa moitié
tu n'es pas une fille banale bien
attention à ces tapoter reportage il va
attention on se concentre la faisait
longtemps que les logements vides à
jovovich attend sûrement attendait là
c'est très important
on se concentre irène premier baiser sur
la bouche sans la langue trop à ça je me
rappelle pas si si si comme c'était
alors la première fois quand même si non
non c'était c'est un garçon que j'ai co
ont fusé gérant sort ensemble à l'école
et puis il arrive une lance un bisou sur
la bouche et puis il part tout de suite
c'est après que je me suis rendu compte
cet ennemi c'était marrant et avec la
longue c'est vous en souvenez je me
souviens j'avais 13 ans c'était à 59
il avait 15 15 mai alors et alors il
foule est en fait beaucoup et moi je
vous mets pas à l'époque
et quand j'ai l'embrasser et j'y
trouvais pas sa sympathie tout et après
je me suis brosser les dents pendant
cinq minutes ça que j'ai décidé de fumer
au beaucoup plus tard que voilà alors
première fois il va vous vous êtes
retrouvé toute nue avec un garçon un peu
un peu bête comme ça un peu bête comme
ça oh oui
ah je crois que c'était en vacances avec
avec mes parents quand j'étais en
espagne et il savait rien moi j'ai
rencontré ce garçon était dans le même
hôtel que nous sait pas comment faire
après oui après on est parti sur la
plage et puis on a aussi un peu le truc
mais ça apprend à marcher ça va pas
marcher
laurent la première fois que tu t'es
retrouvé nu avec un garde son aventure
ça t'a marqué
à yverdon arrive aux choses sérieuses
double tapotage première fois pour de
vrai avec un garçon vraiment c'était
j'ai eu 16 saisons et c'est avec cette
cette personne que j'aimais c'était le
premier coup de foudre et on a attendu
longtemps mais finalement sans vie deux
ans oui ça s'est bien passé
oui très bien bien alors première fois à
trois premiers x 3 bat promet pas trois
sets c'était il ya un mois j'ai eu
j'ai eu 17 ans ça s'est bien passé oui
très bien
première fois avec un animateur télé si
jamais même un co animateur maintenant
du monde comme c'est la première fois
que je te reçois je tiens une interview
première fois
[Musique]
alors jailli ton premier non tout le
monde croit que c'est se met en fête
c'est clair comme julien c'est le nom de
ta mère parce que ton père était assez
volage il a attend mois chez claude
moine
non les stagiaires qui vont sillonner
ton père était quelqu'un d'assez bas
tellement fait pour la pas tellement
fait pour la pour la vie de famille et
quelques jours après la naissance il a
vendu les meubles il a coutume de
l'année y est
dix jours après la naissance il rendit
vite un et six mois plus tard il a
quitté le domicile conjugal et donc ta
mère s'est retrouvé comme ça toute seule
et elle a retrouvé un an après elle a
obligé à l'épouser mais ton vrai nom ton
vrai premier non c'est clair mais cette
semaine c'est huguette clair jusqu'au
mariage jusqu'au mariage de ma mère
c'était clair qui était mannequin chez
fat
oui une très jolie femme et qui vit
toujours et qui vit toujours mais doit
être fier comme je crois que les fans
bien réussi quand même quoi qu'on en
dise c'est vrai que c'est un peu un
voyou mais bon être la maman de johnny
doit elle doit être fier bon je vais
donner du tracas un oui mais bon il fait
faire bien du souci alors ce père léon
se mettre donc johnny vous le reverrez
vingt ans plus tard vous vous avez 21
ans fait le service militaire en
allemagne
et un jour il ya un mec qui vous dit il
fallait à l'entrée de la caserne
on vous y allez c'est un ordre vous y
allez et à ce moment là vous voyez un
type qui se jettent sur vous en disant
johnny johnny monfils est en vous
mettant un ours en peluche dans les bras
et c'était votre père et quelques années
plus tard vous apprendrez qu'en fait
c'était un coup qu'il avait monté avec
les paparazzi oui mais enfin bon ça
s'est passé
ouais je préfère pas
trop parler de ce à quoi vous l'avez
vachement aider à préparer votre père
non oui enfin j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu
mais c'était pas toujours facile parce
que j'avais pris un appartement et puis
je reçois des coups de téléphone dans la
nuit comme quoi il avait mis le feu
ouais dans l'appartement il sait jamais
j'ai essayé beaucoup de choses à un
moment donné j'ai baissé les bras
un message pour dire que tu me pique mes
veines exc non c'est vrai qu'en voulu
acheter des costumes cerrutti d'aller
les revendre quand quand vous lui louer
un appartement il mettait le feu
effectivement donc c'était assez assez
désespérant finalement dossier comme il
était alors même où la maman j'ai baissé
les bras mais j'ai laissé faire et ça
l'a vécu qu'il voulait d'abord reggiani
vous à vous a parlé de lui une fois un
jour je rencontrais djallit qui me dit
tu sais je sais que tu as eu jeu murray
après ce temps permet moi j'allais
prendre des cours tous les tous les
week-ends à bruxelles chez lui c'était
un professeur d'art dramatique est
ordinaire ouais
et puis un jour vous allez l'enterrement
de ce père un petit peu inconnu d'une
certaine façon à un cheikh des camps en
belgique j'ai presque eu ma tristesse
qui va avoir d'abord étonné mais surtout
attristé c'est que j'étais tout seul il
n'y avait personne
ouais c'est bien la première faute était
tout seul mais c'était pas guéri dans
cette histoire c'est un petit peu
déboussolé un d'une certaine façon cette
envie que vous avez eue après de créer
une famille et pas y arriver c'est
peut-être dû à sa finale on le sent
faire de la psychanalyse à deux balles
c'est peut-être ça l'histoire non il
faut d'abord avant de créer une famille
il faut tomber sur la bonne personne
n'était jamais tombé sur la bonne
personne et cette fois-ci bon cette fois
ci je crois que suis bien trompé
ouais ça a l'air intéressant
une femme ex ordinaire avec qui je suis
très heureux et il était temps parce que
alors vous avez été élevé par votre
tante hélène marais votre première scène
c'est à 4 ans vous en souvenez de ça en
47 à londres non dans dans une pièce ce
qui s'appelle caligula de camus fait le
rôle d'un petit 9-6 ne veulent pas du
tout premier souvenir vous souvenez
c'est à londres 12 coincé le doigt dans
un rail d'escalators ensuite sa première
guitare quel âge vers avoir 12 ans ouais
vous étiez à rome avec vos cousins des
stars elie et vous avez à ce moment-là
rencontré un guitariste de flamenco
il choisit une tournée théâtrale invoque
là où il y avait comme ça des tas de
numéro 2 de music hall il y avait des
gitans et avait des acrobates bon et il
y avait dans la troupe des gitans il y
avait un guitariste flamenco qui m'a
appris à jouer un peu du temps
et la jota plein de choses oui et ça
d'un droit non plus et ensuite on a
acheté une guitare donc avec des coques
en ce cas si kaka hormis le retour ou
flamenco le bientôt bientôt premier rôle
au cinéma 1954 en souvenez diabolique
vous aviez une petite annonce dans
france soir et comme il n'est pas de blé
à la maison votre temps de vous à les
emmener là bas j'avais passé un casting
avait pris way dans l'état dans la
classe d'enfants mais j'étais la
figuration ce n'est pas un robin et
j'avais deux phrases à dire qui a été
coupée donc ça ne veut pas très bon mais
on vous voit dans le film vous vous
laver les dents vous savez ça oui au
premier cachet de johnny hallyday en
1955 un oeuvre premier cachet c'est un
coca cola vous aviez chanter davy
crockett sur scène me souviens de ses
chansons davy crockett david avec
raquettes à neige areva 1 j'ai chanté en
duo avec johnny j'ai fait mon premier
duo benzema
vous êtes montés très très tôt sur les
planches
enfin c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on
découvre mais c'est normal parce que
j'ai été élevé par une par une famille
d'artistes engagés beaucoup qui faisait
beaucoup de music hall beaucoup de
cabaret donc je voyais pas très
honnêtement je ne me voyais pas
comptable plus tard je me voyais plutôt
artistes mais ça doit quand même
perturbé sa d'être sur scène aussitôt
non non c'est comme j'ai comme j'en ai
fait mon métier c'est plutôt une chance
pringy j'ai eu le temps d'apprendre
avant d'être connu maintenant ce que je
veux maintenant ce que ce que je
reproche un petit peu c'est qu'on lance
d'aider des gens on essaie de leur
apprendre à danser à chanter en quatre
mois jean les lens comme des stars ils
n'ont pas le temps ils n'ont pas ils
n'ont pas et ils n'ont ils n'ont pas eu
la commande irles la formation la
formation
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
jeanine de strasbourg pour pour aller
sur une scène d'être lancée comme star
il faut apprendre son métier avant et on
leur laisse pas le temps d'apprendre
alors effectivement contrôlés voit sur
scène la première fois les gens peuvent
être peut-être déçu ce n'est pas que le
fait de viol de chantier qui est
important c'est le fait de savoir aller
et sortir d'une scène et ça va bouger
sur une selle en fait un forain quoi je
le suis un oui en quelque sorte oui
c'est pas péjoratif
non non on va pas du tout j'adore les
femmes enceintes alors première bagarre
c'était avec la bande de la trinité non
j'imagine et avait dutronc il y avait
longue crise il y avait dit mitchell
tirez vous preniez des dérouillées par
les mecs de la bande du sacré coeur où
la bande de la bastille ouais ils
étaient plus nombreux que les pieds
combien vaut alors on était une
vingtaine un essai deux sens
j'étais plié votre première petite amie
vous en souvenez ma première petite
taille moi j'ai peur elle vous regarde
elle est la première petite amie c'est
claude pécha bravo genou
en train puisque à l'époque vous n'aviez
pas encore de voiture
votre première idole c'est brassens
c'est vrai vous auriez voulu avoir
brassens avec les grosses moustaches les
vestes en velours il est qui est
rassurant c'est rassurant pas de brel
aussi c'est une de vos premières idoles
et et vous dit s'il avait fait du rock
qui nous aurait tous intérêt c'est vrai
parce que il chante avec sa poésie leila
tapoter sur scène avec l'énergie et le
désespoir d'un rockeur je ne connais pas
d'autres chanteurs que brel 1 qui
transpirait autant et qu'avec il
vomissait avant de rentrer sur celle là
on met tous les records ne produisent
pas avant qui transpirait qui zonaient
qui seront faire autant kaka kaka
bref vous trouvez ça bien là qu'on
réédite des choses qu'ils voulaient pas
voir éditer écouter tout le monde
évidemment curieux longtemps que ça mais
par rapport à sa mémoire je trouve pas
ça très bien alors dit moi il ya des
trucs à toi comme ça qui ont été faits
que personne n'a entendu il doit y avoir
quelques real humer le feu ne s'est
jamais sentie dans ta première qu'est ce
tu t'en souviens c'était une triumph
blanche un bar une terre 3 18 ans dès
qu'il a eu l'âge première boîte
août est sorti ou tu es rentré déjà way
première voiture fut sorti alors là ça
c'est pas j'en ai fait beaucoup
la première à l'époque de la banque de
la trinité j'imagine non album jours ago
trop et c'est sa première boîte comme
propriétaire c'est celle qui ouvre seuil
2003 voilà 2003 il aura fallu attendre
2003 pour que johnny hallyday et sa
boîte à lui
ouais mais ça une histoire cette boîte
que que j'ai monté là on va en parler on
rallume
attention on se concentre et si vous
n'arrivez pas à répondre aux questions c
est vrai une bourrique secrètement la
première fois tout seul je fabrique à
versoix 6 mois à 6 mois déjà
non mais voilà de bonnes réponses brix
j'aimais chanter c'est moi c'est ce que
je me suis dit vous n'aurez pas que des
joker non la première fois avec une
fille est en retard dans mes rêves
le premier bisou le premier bisou à un
garçon un petit bijou dos c'est moi je
suis pas une mi temps 8 ans oui
récréation les 57 quand même hier un je
vois pas pourquoi les mains
le premier baiser là pour le coup le
premier vrai baiser avec un garçon et la
hongrie a deux garçons et l'allant vers
12 ans
le premier flirt poussé poussé jusqu où
fleurs poussent et ça veut dire un truc
laurent laurent tapotage la première
fois l'amour pour de vrai c'est à dire
quinze mois j'ai moi même une fille de
15 ans est-ce que je peux poser une
question non c'est pas un peu tôt 15 ans
j'ai une fille de 14 ans - oui mais qui
en fait son métier non
comme ça
elle est dans une école
c'est un simple [__] c'est
c'est autre chose non simplement est-ce
que c'est pas un peu ton c'est non c'est
pas franchement je serais heureuse et gt
gt prat et jamais je veux tu as peur
voilà quoi bien passé non tu penses à ta
ma fille c'est un peu gênant
j'aimerais qu'il attend de 20 25 elle
tombe bien selon lui une journée des
abeilles avant je lui parlais du pollen
il ya plein de choses on n'a jamais
parlé
vient alors le premier grand amour tu
sais premier chagrin d'amour
ah ouais ah oui qu'est ce qui s'est
passé savais pas quoi ils vous avaient
argué non c'est on s'est quitté en s'est
remis ensemble c'est que tout ça mis
ensemble ça s'en va et ça revient à les
parties devaient partir au soleil
s'apprête qu'on verra demain je crois
qu'il a conduit de l'entrée et s'est
arrêté sur midi à cet instant très
précieux qui va la partie et je suis
parti c'est vraiment le mot paix tant il
semble
la première fois vous avez fait l'amour
à trois tu ne viens la ville oui c'est
ça
jamais non c'est un joker vous vous
dites jamais que si c'est un joker c'est
lamentable
on va faire une interview première alors
votre premier souvenir
ma grand mère qui m'apporte un verre de
lait avec des deux gâteaux les deux
gueules soir votre premier choc choc à
quoi une voiture m'a renversé
vous aviez quel âge en votre premier
mensonge
non merci je m'en tamponne away from her
sait jamais le faire renverser par votre
premier péché par faire l'amour qu'elle
est mignonne cantonaise sadi dans votre
premier coup de foudre
jamais jamais jusqu'à maintenant c'est
vrai jusqu'à maintenant
heureusement il faut que cette émission
avec moi comment il faisait cette
émission avec moi et heureusement que tu
n'es plus là tu ils cassent tous les
coups il est jaloux parce que je veux
embrasser sur la bouche et blanc je
m'intéresse à quelqu'un on ne casse pas
tous les coups la première jeune fille 6
13 07 sur la bouche sans la langue c'est
théo vous savez les camps s'appelle
aller les campagnes heures comme avant
ça existait mais j'étais dans un jamais
jeudi avoir 10 coûte 10 10 on en était
là bas et le premier baiser avec la
langue
c'est avec ce garçon de l'allemand cours
de danse le premier flirt poussé avec un
garçon un flirt poussé enfin vous
appreniez les termes le flirt poussé
alors qu'est ce que c'est
enfin l'or poussés et ce depuis lors
j'avais quand même car si lui montrer
ses deux pouces et sa flore poussées ont
fait un souffle sauve tout voilà a
toujours le même
votre première expérience homosexuelle
ça y est je savais pas de raison merde
c'est un secret je n'ai pas vu combien
fois à trois c'est trop grave si ce
n'est pas moi à peu près 20 10 chez vous
première fois quatre à je regardais
premier chagrin d'amour
oui peut-être j'avais 15 ans on a besoin
d'un garçon qui était un grand succès le
danseur c'est vrai j'étais triste mais
bon c'est pas un chagrin parce que comme
n'y a jamais eu au début c'était pas
vous avez vous avez des races et vous
allez un peu froide avec tout ça n'a pas
l'air de vraiment vous passionnez wendy
sentimentale que ça moi comment pourtant
vous êtes scorpionvous non oui un très
bien et les scorpions seb le sexe quand
même je vous trouve très non j'ai campé
dans laquelle vous êtes sentimentale
quand même sentimental je me demande si
sentimentale que salga finalement
peut-être de temps en temps des fois ça
dépend vous n'êtes pas mauvais en ce
moment un bon déjà raté deux inédits
tube abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu